Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu unsere kleine welt die,
mittlerweile dreiundzwanzig ausgabe korona hält hier das programm am laufen und ja heute möchte ich mal eine,
themen karte ziehen die sich in gewisser hinsicht,
anbietet nämlich die perspektive auf china aber auch taiwan und hongkong werden wir hier beleuchten und mal schauen wie eigentlich die krise sich dort entwickelt hat beziehungsweise,
wie sie sich dort derzeit darstellt und was daraus alles so hervorgeht,
und dazu begrüße ich meine gesprächspartnerin nämlich die katharina katharina hallo.
Katharina vielleicht sollten wir zunächst mal kurz erläutern wer du so bist und was dich hier eigentlich befugt auskunft zu geben du bist auch podcasterin du machst den fern,
ostwärts podcast aber deine verbundenheit mit der chinesischen kultur reicht ja noch sehr viel weiter.
Ja genau also ich.
Ich betreibe mit nils wlan den podcast ich habe aber auch zwei jahre in china und ein jahr in taiwan.
Und promovieren mittlerweile zu chinesischer politik mit dem fokus auch auf der also,
technik politik und netzpolitik und mein großvater ist tatsächlich aus hongkong nach deutschland migriert also es gibt da viele links und.
Das hat dann letztendlich auch irgendwie meine professionelle arbeit jetzt geprägt also sowohl akademisch beim als auch daneben journalistisch mit dem podcast und ich schreibe auch viel für deutschsprachige und mittlerweile englischsprachige medien über die region.
Habe dann im.
Juli zweitausendneunzehn also jetzt bald vor allem ja unter fan auch ein newsletter angefangen wo ich quasi alle zwei wochen einmal aufschreibe was gerade so wichtig war,
in hongkong taiwan und china um so ein bisschen die möglichkeit zu bieten.
Den ereignissen dort zu folgen wenn nicht gerade noch was großes passiert weil oft ostasien in den nachrichten landet wenn gerade irgendwie was wichtiges und groß ist da zum beispiel ein virus oder.
Irgendwie ein großer skandal oder irgendwie sowas und aber es passiert ja die ganze zeit etwas und gerade auch um so ein bisschen eine regelmäßige.
Berichterstattung zu den hongkonger protest zu bieten wir haben diese newsletter ins leben gerufen.
Dein studium war ja internationale beziehung wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Genau also ich bin in den politikwissenschaften und meine felder sind internationale beziehungen und vergleichende politikwissenschaft.
Also das sowohl ein kulturellen als auch ein spezifisch politischen blick auf die gesamtsituation.
Genau und natürlich auch einen sozialen weil ich halt einfach immer noch viele freunde ihnen dort habe und ich bin halt einfach auch noch viel eingebunden in sachen die halt einfach vor ort passieren.
Gut ich wollte jetzt mal ein wenig eben aus dieser spezifischen perspektive heraus mal zurückblicken auf den ursprung dieser ganzen krise in der wir uns jetzt befinden da.
Geht es natürlich dann zunächst einmal um die region wuhan und ja sozusagen der ground siro dieser ganzen virus geschichte.
Jetzt ist hat sich ja so ein bisschen der staub gelegt und ich denke man weiß jetzt auch sehr viel mehr als das vielleicht in den ersten tagen und wochen einem so entgegenkam.
Wie lief das jetzt eigentlich aus deiner perspektive,
ab was ist eigentlich wann passiert vor allem wann gab es denn eigentlich die ersten fälle und die ersten,
berichte dass hier irgendwas im argen liegen könnte.
Also das kommt so ein bisschen darauf an wo man wo man schaut also die.
Ich glaube das war ein bericht von zeichen also man muss dazu sagen viele dieser sachen wissen wir nur weil chinesische medien in den letzten monaten unheimlich gut investigative berichterstattung geliefert haben unter anderem die zeitung zeigt ihnen.
Also die ersten fälle gab es wohl anfang dezember
es gibt auch ein lied ein geliebtes dokument dass das sind zufolge angeblich ist schon ein fall ende november gab es ist aber weniger sicher aber der fall im anfang dezember ist der ist der ist nachgewiesen also es ist relativ sicher,
der ist glaube ich sogar im verlinkt wurden das heißt so den ganzen dezember über gab es relativ immer wieder so fälle von merkwürdigen lungenentzündungen.
Und leute die in krankenhäusern in johann arbeiten haben da schon angefangen.
So ein bisschen vorsichtig zu werden haben wir gesagt das sieht wirklich merkwürdig aus sie konnte es nicht einordnen sie konnten es nicht vernünftig behandeln sie konnten auch nicht wirklich so wussten auch nicht was die leute eigentlich haben,
und das heißt im dezember gab es schon diese ersten gerüchte dass es so rum ging also eigentlich sind sie nicht gerücht es waren halt,
ärztinnen also unter anderem eben dieser augenarzt lieber jan da mittlerweile auch berühmt geworden ist dafür und aber auch andere ärztinnen die zum beispiel bekannte in gruppen gewarnt haben und gesagt haben es gibt ja diese ganzen fälle seit vorsichtig
zum beispiel das ist ein augenarzt der mehrere fälle von so einer.
Sehr verdächtigen lungenentzündungen gesehen hat und der dann eine gruppe gewarnt hat mit leuten mit denen zusammen medizin studiert hatte.
Das heißt so dieses netzwerk der prophet der angestellten im gesundheitssystem hat schon sehr früh angeschlagen und die leute haben sehr früher angefangen einander davor zu warnen dass ihr etwas merkwürdiges und vermutlich gefährliches umgeht.
Das war also es war den ganzen dezember über so und dann wurde aber.
Frage findet hat gewarnt also dass es ist jetzt so im nachhinein rausgekommen dass das so im privaten umfeld war oder hat das damals schon auch in irgendeiner form eine teil öffentlichkeit erreicht.
Also es hat die teile öffentlichkeit erreicht dahingehend dass am ersten januar liebe und lernen und sieben andere leute von der polizei beziehen,
dafür angemeckert wurden dass sie gerüchte verbreitet haben und dass also durch diese ganzen durch diese ganzen unterhaltung,
gab es dann zusätzlich nach langsam auch druck auf die regierung in johann und die gesundheitskommissar johanna und am einunddreißigsten zwölften zum ersten mal offiziell gesagt dass es siebenundzwanzig fälle eine unbekannten art von lungenentzündung also eine unbekannten promo gibt das heißt das war so das erste offizielle lebenszeichen davon,
das da was im busch ist und kurz darauf hat china wohl auch offiziell der bescheid gesagt dass es diese fälle gibt.
Deswegen heißt es auch corvin neunzehn und nicht kurve zwanzig.
Genau also.
Noch so.
Sache von wirklich zwei tagen.
Aber das muss man halt einfach auch schon sehen also es gab diese fälle und aber es war einfach noch so ein bisschen so so würde place man konnte es noch nicht so richtig einordnen und zu dem zeitpunkt wurden ärztinnen die darüber gesprochen haben leute gewarnt haben wirklich von der polizei dafür belangt,
das muss man wirklich auf dem muss man wirklich auf dem schirm haben und es gab auch einen bericht dass zum beispiel am dritten ersten die nationale gesundheitskommissar laboren die schon,
von diesem virus hatten gesagt hat dass sie diese samples bitte zerstören sollen.
Und ärztinnen wurde von ihrem krankenhäusern gesagt sie sollten nicht mit den sie sollten nicht darüber sprechen dass es diese fälle gibt obwohl sie schon so lange scans gesehen haben wo man richtig gesehen hat wie krass die lungen angegriffen.
Also das war so so anfang januar wurden haben sich diese gerüchte wirklich zunehmend verdichtet weil es immer mehr hinweise darauf gab dass dieses virus wirklich ernst zu nehmen ist.
Und dann ist etwas eine sache die man in china verstehen muss ist dass die es gibt man stellt sich das immer sehr zentralisiert vor aber es gibt verschiedene ebenen auch der regierung.
Und.
Die in diesem fall ist es relativ wichtig zu verstehen dass die stadt wo haben und die provinz eben auch eine provinz und eine lokale haben die selber politisches interesse daran haben gut dazustehen.
Und verdächtiger weise gab es vom sechsten bis zum siebzehnten januar januar zwei sehr wichtige politische treffen in der u-bahn und diesen elf tagen wurde kein einziger neuer fall offiziell bekanntgegeben.
Also muss man muss man sich vorstellen so ist es ist dann sowas wo wahrscheinlich im nachhinein.
Gibt es sowas sehr wahrscheinlich ist es dass die stadtregierung versucht hat zu verhindern dass diese fälle rauskommen damit sie eben gut da dasteht damit das alles stabil aussieht damit das alles perfekt aussieht für dieses lokale treffen was sie hatten.
Und in der zeit wo der bei unter anderem gab es offiziell die ersten toten,
es gab auch offiziell den ersten fall außerhalb von chinas nämlich eine chinesische person die nach thailand gereist war
es gibt zum beispiel den ersten fall in japan das heißt zu dem zeitpunkt wo das alles so runtergespielt wurde von der lokalredaktion hat sich das virus definitiv weiter ausgebreitet sowohl innerhalb von china als auch über china hinaus.
Aber die regierung hat das alles runtergespielt und gesagt das ist alles okay leute sollen sich keine sorgen machen es gibt kein anderes zu sorge und am achtzehnten januar gab es auch ein riesiges so ein so ein buffet so ein bankett für in in einem stadtteil von johann.
Wo dann auch diverse leute die danach hingegangen waren danach krank geworden sind weil die regierung die lokalen regierung versucht hat das alles runterzuspielen.
Am zwanzigsten januar ging es ging es dann erst offiziell los also wirklich drei tage oder so weil nach diesem treffen als es dann vorbei war dies politisch treffen ging auf einmal die fälle hoch also die offiziell anerkannten fälle also es wird davon ausgegangen dass die quasi runtergespielt wurden und vertuscht wurden für mehrere tage
und dann als dieses treffen vorbei wir haben sie dann gesagt okay jetzt gehen wir zu dass es diese menschen gibt die das virus haben.
Und am zwanzigsten januar hat dann selber endlich gesagt ja wir müssen jetzt hier so quasi so ein bisschen so die nationale richtung so ein bisschen vorgegeben wenn man jetzt das und das.
Das ist ein so ein bisschen so ein achtzigjähriger christian,
der in china wirklich sehr respektiert wird hat an dem tag dann auch gesagt offiziell ja es gibt übertragung von mensch zu mensch von diesem virus was halt bis dann bis zu dem zeitpunkt in china.
Nie so bestätigt worden war das heißt der zwanzigste januar ist im endeffekt der tag wo es so richtig wohl so richtig klar wurde dass das hier ist jetzt auch ernst nimmt auch offizielles ernst genommen hat.
Ist denn da zu dem zeitpunkt der virus als solcher auch schon isoliert gewesen oder hat man quasi nur die krankheit gesehen.
Nee also wenn ich mich recht erinnere wurde also ich hatte eben schnell wenn anfang januar wurde laboren gesagt sie sollten die samples zerstören und ich glaube der also soweit ich das weiß wurden die ersten sequenz sind schon ende dezember anfang januar rausgeschickt.
Das muss genau dazu müsste ich dann nachschauen aber das wurde definitiv relativ früh in china und auch in hongkong sequenzielle.
Glaube dass weiß ich jetzt nicht genau aber ich meine das ist auch eine deutsche firma gab die ein sehr frühen test hergestellt hat zu dem zeitpunkt auch schon.
Vielleicht zu wuhan nochmal
das ist ja wie mit so vielen chinesischen städten so man kennt die halt immer nicht man kennt so hongkong man kennt shanghai picking und
das war's dann wahrscheinlich für die meisten auch schon,
das ist ja eine riesen stadt zehn millionen einwohner ich vermute mal das umfeld drum herum trägt dann auch nochmal so einiges dazu wie wie muss man sich diese region vorstellen wie wirtschaftlich aktiv ist das ist das auch so ein
powerhouse chinas wie steht das da.
Schon also einfach eine riesige stadt also es ist viel industrie da und das ist auch ein super wichtiger dreh- und angelpunkt so für reisen und also warenlieferung durch das land also da geht einfach super viel an menschen und auch waren und transporter geht super viel dadurch.
Bin auch lange schon nicht mehr gewesen und deswegen kann ich die stadt selber so nicht.
Also ich kenne die stadt nicht besonders gut ich habe sie vor ich glaube zweitausendelf oder das letzte mal besucht habe sie aber im endeffekt wie einfach wie ein
von vielen großen chinesischen städten ernährung und das war einfach sehr lebendig es waren damals ich war damals relativ warm war man ist viel draußen sitzt hier draußen es gibt ein super gutes nudelgericht dort mit sie so einer sesam paste dass man dann gut zum frühstück essen kann
also ja es ist halt einfach eine eine großstadt.
Die auch vernetzt ist also die die wo wo viel flugverkehr ist und so weiter man ist es wahrscheinlich eh in den meisten metropolen so aber es ist jetzt auch nicht jetzt irgendwie so eine so eine stadt die aus irgendwelchen gründen besonders landwirtschaftlich geprägt wäre oder sonst irgendwas ne okay.
Nee absolut nicht im gegenteil also definitiv sehr viel industrie und auch viele leute also es gibt viele
migrantische also wandarbeit die halt nach woran kommen um dort zu arbeiten also die zum beispiel aus allen anteilen der provinz huber dahin kommen oder aus anderen teilen des landes tatsächlich um dort zu arbeiten und da und geld zu verdienen.
Musste diese stadt in alarmbereitschaft gesetzt werden und dann ging es aber auch glaube ich relativ schnell mit dem mit dem look down los also das maßnahmen ergriffen wurden oder.
Also ich hatte ja gesagt dass wir am zwanzigsten ersten wurde offiziell quasi anerkannt dass es ein problem gibt so ein bisschen und am dreiundzwanzigsten wurde die gesamte stadt quasi geschlossen also es kam auch fürs wurde relativ kurzfristig angekündigt,
um zu verhindern dass leute noch rausgehen und der locker und war auch am anfang gar nicht so krass also im sinne von es wurde zwar also es gab keine flügel-mann es gab keine busse mehr,
ich erinnere mich noch daran dass leute berichtet haben dass man mit privaten autos wo noch rausgekommen ist für für eine ganze weile.
Es gab zum beispiel auch berichte von leuten die gesagt haben die dann zum beispiel auf den sozialen medien stolz darüber berichtet haben dass sie aus woanders noch acht peking geschafft haben wo dann andere leute gesagt haben so hallo geht's noch.
Das war auch der zeitraum wo die ersten videos rausgekommen sind also ich glaube das ist etwas was.
In deutschland habe ich das gefühl dass es teils erst angekommen ist als diese krassen videos aus new york und aus italien irgendwie kam wo man,
irgendwie verzweifelte ärztinnen gesehen hat und diese ganzen überfüllten krankenhäuser aber das sind videomaterial dass ich im januar schon aus wuhan gesehen habe also das ging halt auch überall viral,
im chinesischen netz wo man schon videos gesehen hat von krankenhäusern die etwas super voll sind wo,
mindestens einem krankenhaus leute einfach auf dem boden saßen und auch was richtig krass war waren,
waren mehrere videos von ärztinnen die einfach offensichtlich total erschöpft waren und wirklich ins telefon geschrien haben und geschrieben haben ihr müsst uns leute schicken ihr müsst uns material schicken wir haben nicht nur die leute die halt einfach teils stundenlang geschichten gearbeitet haben um sich,
um sich um diese um sich in diese patientinnen zu kümmern und das war auch der zeitpunkt wo dann diese ganzen.
Geschichten losging von menschen die gestorben waren also sei es dass sie im krankenhaus irgendwo gestorben waren und sich niemand um sie kümmern konnte,
oder aber auch dass es menschen waren außerhalb des krankenhauses das ist jetzt auch eine geschichte die wir jetzt auch aus die wird auch aus new york immer wieder hören dass leute die nicht in die über über die krankenhäuser man hat komplett überlastet dann zu dem zeitpunkt.
Das heißt viele leute konnten nicht in die krankenhäuser also gerade leute die weniger krank waren haben konnten lange wurden einfach nicht zugelassen es gab immer wieder geschichten von leuten die versucht hatten ins krankenhaus zu kommen und ich konnten und dann teils zuhause gestorben sind,
also oft sind es geschichte von den angehörigen erzählt wurden oder teils dass leute gestorben sind ohne dass irgendwie anerkannt wurde dass es eben saß kopf zwei war so kurbelt neunzehn wurden sie gestorben sind also das ist wirklich eine unheimliche.
Tragödie also diese ich glaube diese drei wochen zwei drei wochen es war wirklich eine zeit des unheimlichen unvorstellbaren traumas für diese gesamte stadt,
es ist krass wie sich diese szenen dann ein paar wochen später im erst in der lombardei und dann eben auch in new york wiederholt haben.
Der look down war ja dann relativ schnell auch sehr umfangreich also wenn ich das richtig sehe duft die leute ja auch die stadt dann überhaupt nicht mehr verlassen also es wurde sozusagen
komplett abgeriegelt klar züge vor nicht mehr flugzeuge zu dem zeitpunkt ja ohnehin schon nicht mehr und alle mussten dann in ihren wohnungen bleiben oder wie extrem war das dann.
Genauso es war erst noch relativ locker so man könnte zum beispiel noch raus irgendwie und man muss da sollte halt eigentlich drin bleiben alle mussten dann irgendwie von zu hause arbeiten,
ich glaube man könnte sagen die ersten ich glaube so ein zwei wochen waren wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen vergleichbarer mit dem was wir jetzt auch in deutschland hatten für ein paar wochen.
Aber viele leute sind halt einfach zu hause geblieben und ich glaube gerade wenn man diese ganzen bilder gesehen hat dann hat man sich halt auch entschieden zu hause zu bleiben.
Und anfang februar wurde das dann nochmal deutlich strikter gemacht wo sie dann angefangen haben,
sie haben versucht haben versucht von haus zu haus zu gehen und wirklich jede person zu testen in der stadt und wirklich herauszufinden wie schlimm das ist mit dem virus und eine sache die auch sehr wichtig war die sie gemacht haben ist dass sie angefangen haben leute zentralisiert unter quarantäne zu stellen,
weil bis anfang februar hatten sie dann gesagt wenn jemand das hatte und nicht so schlimm war dann haben sie den leuten gesagt sie sollen zuhause bleiben oder in kontakt wurde gesagt sie sollen zuhause bleiben.
Das ist jetzt auch etwas es gibt ein papier einer statistikerin skihang,
von harvard die auch gesagt hat als anfang februar dann zentralisiert garantiert wurde so dass leute dann in hotels unter quarantäne gestellt wurden um nicht mehr die leute in ihrem eigenen haushalt anzustecken dann haben hat die stadt begonnen das virus langsam unter kontrolle zu bekommen.
Und das war eben anfang februar wo das nochmal deutlich strikter gemacht wurde wo es dann auch zunehmend so war dass die leute dass man nur noch irgendwie einmal pro woche aus dem wohnkomplex raus durfte um einzukaufen oder so und das dürfte nur eine person sein das ist wirklich sehr eingeschränkt wurde wie sehr man sich noch bewegen durfte.
Was war das für quarantäne orte dann also die wurden dann erst geschaffen oder das war dein hotels oder.
Es gab ich habe damit der mit der mit der statistikerin darüber geredet es gab also einerseits gab es quarantäne für leute die positiv getestet wurden aber milde symptome hatten
die wurden dann quasi alle zusammen in so einem kranken krankenhäuser gesteckt oder ich glaube teils auch teils auch in diese,
neuen krankenhäuser um quasi zu verhindern dass die andere menschen anstecken,
wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe wurden leute die enge kontakte von diesen leuten waren die wurden in hotels gesteckt zur quarantäne,
das heißt wenn du einen engen kontakt mit einer person hattest die positiv getestet wurde dann musstest du irgendwie zwei wochen lang in hotel regelmäßig temperatur checken und.
Regelmäßig und dann zum ende hin wo die leute auch getestet und wenn man zweimal negative getestet wurde durfte man quasi wieder aus der quarantäne raus weil dann gesagt okay du hast es definitiv nicht,
aber es war halt ein sehr aggressive strategie um sicher zu gehen dass die leute niemanden in der stadt nochmal anstecken das nochmal neu infektionskrankheiten.
Aber das wurde akzeptiert also meine china hat ja schon eine gewisse erfahrung mit viren fällen das ist ja jetzt nicht das erste mal dass das ist eine epidemie gab.
Ich erinnere mich persönlich an saß aber also damit ich weiß nicht wie viel das damit zu tun hat also man muss schon sagen dass die chinesische regierung bei saß deutlich länger versucht hat das zu verschweigen.
Ich denke ein faktor ist sicher auch dass es mittlerweile schwieriger geworden ist solche sachen einfach zu verstecken.
Weil man wirklich einfach auch wieder gesehen hat dass die sozialen medien einfach eine riesige rolle darin gespielt haben informationen zu verbreiten weil die leute halt auch wissen dass die regierung ihnen sachen verschweigt
wenn wir diese ganzen informationen diese ganzen gerüchte online herum gehen auch wenn sie zensiert werden die leute wissen das ja die kriegen das ja mit und das hat natürlich auch für druck gesorgt,
die leute haben gesagt wir müssen uns jetzt sagen was wir müssen uns jetzt sagen was wirklich was wirklich sache ist eine sache die ich auch noch ganz spannend fand ist dass zum beispiel auch.
Für eine weile also zwischenzeitlich wurde die regierung kritisiert dafür dass sie nicht stark genug reagiert also sie das problem ist ja dass dieses virus kurz vor dem beginn von chinesisch steuer wirklich.
Angefangen hat sich richtig auszubreiten und zwischen diese steuer.
Bei sind die ganzen das ist quasi der die eine zeit des jahres wo leute wirklich frei haben und alle durch das ganze land reisen um ihren familien neuer zu feiern und.
Es gab zum beispiel aktionen online wo leute gesagt haben du musst quasi aktionen gab um die regierung zu bitten die ferien zu verlängern um zu verhindern dass die ganzen leute die jetzt quasi nach hause gereist war nach den ferien wieder zurück in ihre wohnorte fahren und dann dort das virus weiter verbreiten.
Gleichzeitig ist es aber auch so dass die es auch einfach enorme also es gab auch einfach enorme kritik also ich glaube es gibt so zwei man muss ein bisschen was man wirklich unterscheiden muss ist.
Die situation in johan selber und die situation im rest chinas wo hannes wo ist ich hatte es ja eben schnell zeit einfach dieses also dieses enorme trauma das die stadt durchgemacht hat.
Ich glaube es gab sicher auch kritik daran wie diese ganzen maßnahmen durchgesetzt wurden weil das teils auch einfach sehr.
Also die regierung hat halt auch panik geschoben die die wissen auch dass dieses virus für sie ein riesigen es ist ein riesiger gefahr so legitimationsbasis und auch für die wirtschaft und die wollten das halt einfach.
Alles biegen und brechen unter kontrolle bekommen,
dahingehend gab es dann natürlich auch kritiker diesen an diesen maßnahmen und es gab immer wieder geschichten von zum beispiel kindern die von ihnen eltern getrennt kennt getrennt worden oder so aber ich glaube was noch krasser war weil diese enorme kritik auch daran dass die regierung das ganze halt verschwiegen hat,
am anfang also das ist halt immer mehr berichte gab in diesem zeitraum auch also das war so ein zeitraum von zwei drei wochen in dem chinesische medien auch relativ frei berichten,
also es wirklich relativ wenig zensur gab und ganz viel investigative berichterstattung rauskam und wo dann einfach zunehmend klar wurde dass das ganze vertuscht worden war um besonders auf jeden fall von der lokalradio und eventuell auch von der zentralregierung,
die leute sind einfach unheimlich wütend gewesen und das hat man unter anderem dann zum beispiel gesehen,
als lieben lernen also dieser augenarzt nicht schon mal erwähnt hatte der hatte ja seine seine kommilitoninnen gewarnt und ist dann im februar selber an kohfeldt neunzehn erkrankt und auch an kohfeldt neunzehn gestorben.
Sein tod war etwas hat im chinesischen internet auf das ausgelöst was ich noch nie gesehen habe also es war wirklich ein unglaublicher unheimlicher zorn,
eine unglaubliche wut und nachher eine unglaubliche trauer ist es quasi zum symbolbild geworden dafür
für diese informationspolitik der regierung deutschlands sagt er hat euch gewarnt ihr habt anstand statt auf ihn zu hören habt ihr bestraft und jetzt ist er selber in diesem virus gestorben und.
Das war in der ersten februar woche und da ist dann tatsächlich auch der hashtag ich möchte meinungsfreiheit viral gegangen also solche sachen sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen im chinesischen als das war wirklich ein absolut krasser moment.
Das war aber auch etwas wo also wo quasi dieses gefühl was ich schön woran gab wo die leute das gefühl haben dass sie quasi allein gelassen worden waren wo sich das dann so ein bisschen auf das ganze den ganzen rest des landes auch ausgebreitet hat.
Das ist einmal so dass das war aus dem ganzen land stattfand und ich glaube die stadt woran selber.
Es gibt gemischte gefühle glaube ich jetzt gerade im nachhinein zum zeitpunkt gab es viel unzufriedenheit mit der regierung mittlerweile kann ich ihn natürlich so ein bisschen so.
Bisschen gut dastehen wenn es ein bisschen auf den rest der welt zeigt und sagt so haja hier guck mal bei uns also es war nicht geil aber es besser als woanders so ein bisschen also das ist so ein bisschen der tenor,
es ist echt der tenor so ein bisschen auch,
aber gerade in der stadt selber die leute sind wo haben wissen auch dass sie es wurde öfters gesagt dass die stadt wohin geopfert wurde für den rest des zum wohl des restes landes.
Weil im endeffekt die stadt quasi zugemacht wurde und so besser gesagt wurde ihr seht jetzt wie ihr klarkommt.
Um zu verhindern dass es virus sich in andere städte in china ausbreitet und es wird sich jetzt zeigen.
Wie sehr diese wut darüber und die unzufriedenheit darüber nachhaltig in der stadt vorhanden bleibt also ich das ist einfach eine frage die man gerade auch nicht beantworten kann und es scheint also berichten zufolge also leute die darüber die mit leuten in woran sprechen also zum beispiel financial times hat,
johan der guardian war aber das ist echt gewünscht es gibt ein paar leute die dann wirklich mittlerweile dieses offizielle narrativ,
akzeptieren und sagen okay ja es war nicht gut aber es war es wert ähm es gibt wirklich auch,
einige leute die sagen ne es kann einfach nicht sein und die diese wut auch nochmal einfach nur mit sich rumtragen ich glaube man muss auch einfach diese gesamte stadt wurde halt einfach krass traumatisiert.
In dieser zeit und ich glaube es ist schwer zu sagen gerade wie nah also ich glaube es wird sehr nachhaltig sein aber es ist schwer zu sagen wie sich das politisch auswirken wird wenn natürlich viel damit zusammenhängt wie schuhe zu schreiben.
Und wie auch die wahrnehmung im rest von china ist.
Jagt also rest von china schon aber einfach also ich muss glaube ich diese stadt selber auch einfach als.
Wirklich betrachten weil der rest chinas kann halt so ein bisschen sagen okay das war nicht geil aber es war schon so dieses jahr okay man steckt dann halt so wie zu hause fest und man konnte konnten weniger rausgehen also deutschland aber.
Die meisten die meisten waren halt vor allem gelangweilt und waren nie wirklich selber in gefahr,
aber die leute also die leute das war einfach eine stadt also zwischenzeitlich gab's glaube ich eine todesliste von vier prozent oder so aus den aus den aus den fällen und es ist auch immer noch nicht ganz klar wie viele leute wirklich gestorben sind.
Das ist ähnlich ist ähnlich wie new york wo jetzt irgendwie jede person oder jede zweite person jemanden kennt der gestorben ist an diesem virus und das also das das hinterlässt einfach wirklich krasse spuren und die leute aus wuhan wurden auch es ist nicht so dass dann auch irgendwie.
Unbedingt china zusammenhält oder so.
Stattdessen wurden leute aus wuhan auch im ganzen rest des landes dann auf einmal diskriminiert als dieses virus als klar wurde dass dieses virus in johan umgeht und zum beispiel leute die in ihrem.
Im ausweis stehen haben dass sie geboren wurden oder dort registriert sind die haben dann keine konnten keine konnten keine hotels befinden im rest des landes oder wurden wir aus ihren wohnungen rausgeschmissen oder solche sachen weil dann halt auf einmal jede person,
stigmatisiert wurde als eine person die dieses virus hat also so ein bisschen.
So eine diskriminierung die dann im ausland anfing also im ausland auch in deutschland zum beispiel nichts dann ja schon im januar los dass leute die asiatisch aussahen wirklich zunehmenden rassismus erfahren haben und so behandelt wurden als hätten sie das virus und diese erfahrung die.
Adriatische gelesene menschen im westen gemacht haben mit dem zeitraum haben auch sehr früh leute aus wuhan selber innerhalb von innerhalb von china gemacht und das heißt ich glaube deswegen muss man wirklich.
Johann und die provinz selber so ein bisschen gesondert vom rest des landes behandeln weil sie auch diese epidemie sehr anders erlebt haben.
Woran ethnisch irgendwie besonders unterschiedlich oder ist es eher so mainstream china.
Händchen größtenteils.
Also die sind jetzt sozusagen in der regel als solche optisch nicht sofort erkennbar dass sie aus dieser region kommen.
Genau aber das problem ist halt wenn du dich irgendwo registrierst dann also zum beispiel wenn du dich bei einem hotel anmeldest bist du halt normalerweise dein ausweis vorlegen und in dem ausweis steht halt drin wo du registriert bist oder wo du herkommst.
Okay aber es ist quasi nur auf datenbasis jetzt nicht dass da noch ein spezieller indischer hintergrund dazu kommt.
Nee genau.
Und wird denn jetzt wird denn jetzt die region auch vom staat besonders wieder
und gefördert also gibt es jetzt auch nennenswerte maßnahmen und und und hilfen die sichtbar sind und zu sagen okay alles klar das war zwar jetzt scheiße aber jetzt hat der rest des landes auch die kraft euch wieder mit hochzuziehen.
Woran auch so wichtig ist dann würde man das ja erwarten oder.
Also es wurde relativ früh wollte die regierung das quasi das wirtschaftliche aktivität wieder anläuft aber das war auch vor allem im rest des landes also dass da jetzt groß.
Forderung in die region geht hätte ich jetzt nicht irgendwie mitbekommen bisher es kann sein dass es einfach übersehen habe ich glaube aber auch dass.
Also das ist halt einfach nicht nur wirtschaftlich und ich glaube dieses also dieses dieses emotionale was da noch eine große rolle spielt noch einfach dieses gefühl für politisch geopfert worden zu sein ich glaube das ist etwas was auch,
wirtschaftliche förderung nicht wieder gut machen wird wobei es natürlich definitiv der fall ist dass es auch.
Dass die leute in der stadt einen enormen wirtschaftlichen preis gezahlt haben dafür und zum beispiel gerade also das ist es auch wieder das gleiche muster was man jetzt gerade in anderen teilen der welt beobachtet dass im endeffekt,
die leute die von niedriges einkommen haben das ist ein zweifel die sind die als erstes davon betroffen sind also zum beispiel wandarbeit in woran die,
einfach wochenlang dann keine arbeit finden.
Und auch teils immer noch keine arbeit finden das sind die einen die halt einfach gar kein einkommen haben und die anderen sind die leute die in so.
So wirklich schlecht bezahlten jobs arbeiten wie zum beispiel die dann zum beispiel das essen ausliefern oder die überall sauber machen muss also die ganzen straßenfeger innen und auch die leute die im krankenhäusern putzen mussten also im zweifel sind es diejenigen die den größten,
neben den leuten im gesundheitssystem die größte last tragen mussten und aber wie in so vielen politischen kontexten sind es im zweifel auch diejenigen.
Die wenigsten politischen einfluss haben weil sie sind nicht teil der wohlhabenden mittelschicht die sich die chinesische regierung im zweifel so als unterstützung erhalten möchte.
Ich glaube aber morgen ist auch ein bisschen noch zu noch zu früh um wirklich zu beurteilen inwieweit ich inzwischen regierung auch versucht es wieder gut zu machen was dort passiert ist weil wir einfach uns immer noch an dieser phase der sehr langsam behutsam öffnung befinden.
Also offiziell wurde ohan anfang april wieder öffnet aber was man alles an bericht mitbekommt ist noch sehr zaghaft und behutsam.
Eine sache die man auch bedenken muss ist das ist auch ein erfahrung die ich selber gemacht habe und es ist auch zum beispiel lilly chor die für den guardian in china ist hat darüber geschrieben.
Man wenn man mit leuten in wo hand redet das ist unheimlich schwierig gerade weil einerseits gibt es definitiv politisches interesse daran die leute daran zu hindern mit medien zu sprechen dass das leute begeben sich durchaus auch in gefahr und.
Werden im zweifel von der polizei angesprochen wenn sie mit der ausländischen presse sprechen weil einfach ein interesse daran besteht jetzt dass die geschichte von johann als.
Triumph dargestellt wird und nicht als etwas durch das dass leute durchlitten haben,
gleichzeitig ist es einfach auch so dass also zum beispiel darüber geschrieben dass sie halt das gefühl hat sie zwingt leute ihr trauma nochmal neu zu durchleben und
viele sind einfach noch nicht unbedingt bereit darüber zu sprechen und ich habe auch versucht ein paar leute zu kontaktieren und mit denen zu sprechen und die haben alle gesagt ich bin noch nicht so weit ich kann ich kann einfach noch nicht
das heißt diese geschichte ist einfach auch noch nicht vorbei.
Kannst du noch mal schildern was was jetzt so primär dieses traumatisierende element war also war das jetzt einfach nur weil diese quarantäne maßnahmen so echt
extrem waren oder war das so eine so eine hilflosigkeit die sich dort breit gemacht hat weil man die ganze zeit das gefühl hat man man kann niemanden mehr glauben also was ist so da die essenz was was
am meisten wirkung.
Ich glaube einmal die hilflosigkeit aber zum anderen einfach auf diese komplette diese brutalität des virus weil also zum beispiel es gibt geschichten von schicksalen wo leute,
also wirklich von leuten zum beispiel wenn man dann mitbekommen hat dass wir die leute in ihren wohnungen sterben oder es gab so ein bericht von einer person ich weiß nicht ob das mittlerweile verifiziert wurde die darüber gesprochen hat ihre beiden eltern eine nach der anderen gestorben sind.
Oder von einem mann aus der umgebung von johann das sind frau gestorben ist und er hat sie quasi ins krankenhaus gebracht und durfte sie dann nicht mehr sehen und fünf tage später oder so halt einfach ihre asche wieder bekommen mit einem zettel wo drauf stand dass sie in der lungenentzündung gestorben ist.
Und gleichzeitig haben die leute halt auch mitbekommen was in den krankenhäusern um sie herum passiert ist also das war wirklich absoluter notstand also wirklich,
jede person die da im krankenhaus gegangen wäre das ist in ein krankenhaus gegangen zumindest für einen zeitraum das komplett überlastet war,
es sind auch wirklich viele angestellte des gesundheitssystems sind soweit ich das weiß auch krank geworden und hat gestorben.
Also es ist einfach diese absolute brutalität und dann dieses gefühl dass allein gelassen seins das hat die stadt zugemacht wurde es war auch,
auch das problem dass es lange nicht genug schutzausrüstung gab für das gesundheitssystem,
und das ist glaub ich erst mal für diese kombination von von dingen und das wurde dann eben und währenddessen saßen die leute halt alle zuhause und konnten nicht mehr raus und haben sich halt allein gelassen gefühlt.
Denkst du denn dass du hattest ja vorhin das hättest du jetzt noch nie gesehen dass die leute jetzt mal akut meinungsfreiheit eingefordert hätten,
denkst du also muss man das jetzt als was
einschätzen was gegebenenfalls eine langfristigen effekte haben könnte es ist nur etwas was jetzt mal in der spitze auch sichtbar wurde um danach eigentlich wieder in vergessenheit zu geraten.
Glaube er letzteres also ich finde ich glaube es ist zu ich glaube es schwingt viel so wunschdenken mit wenn man sagt dass es jetzt bedeutet dass es dass die leute die regierung stürzen würden oder so.
Ja gut soweit wollte ich jetzt gar nicht gehen ne ich meine das kann ja auch sein dass das jetzt vielleicht nur ein anfang ist ja und bei der nächsten krise kommt das dann erst wieder hoch.
Ich glaube das problem ist so ein bisschen also ich habe ein argument gesehen was ich ganz interessant fand dass diese ganzen forderungen nach mehr.
Aggressiveren maßnahmen eigentlich der regierung die schuld geben dafür dass der staat nicht stark genug war es ist argument habe ich schon gesehen.
Also das eigentlich im endeffekt die leute ein stärkeren staat wollen sie quasi beschützt.
Und ich glaube eine sache ist aber auch dass ein ein wichtiger faktor anfang februar war dass es viel unsicherheit gab und zum ersten mal ein sehr sehr langer zeit auch die chinesische mittelschicht im ganzen land sich selber in gefahr wähnte so ein bisschen und ich glaube das hat auch so ein bisschen damit reingespielt.
Da sind wir ja auch in europa jetzt ne.
Also das auf einmal berühren dich diese ganzen sachen selber und dann wirst du sauer auf die regierung,
ich glaube deswegen ist es aber auch so dass leute die zum beispiel in irgendwelche kian oder shanghai oder peking sitzen und die dann waren dann kurz sauer weil sie zu dem zeitpunkt noch dachten dass es sie vielleicht auch betreffen könnte aber.
Die stimmung ist definitiv ich würde sagen die stimmung ist tendenziell umgesprungen zu dass dieses offizielle narrativ des chinesischen triumphes gegen das virus.
Jetzt glaube ich überhaupt genommen hat besonders bei den leuten die eben nicht persönlich betroffen waren weil es dann glaube ich einfacher ist das versagen die regierung auch zu ignorieren.
Insofern ist die strategie der regierung jetzt damit groß rumzuprobieren auch erfolgreich gewisser hinsicht.
Ja absolut also nach einem was ich höre schon also zum beispiel auch das,
es gibt es wird ja auch dieses gerücht wolter munter verbreitet dass das virus vielleicht aus den usa kommt es gab zwischendurch diese verschwörungstheorie,
es soweit sein kann ich aus china kommt aber dann sogar von der afd in deutschland teils aufgegriffen wurde dass das virus aus einem labor in den usa kommt amerikanischen soldaten in den ingo hand verbreitet.
Also es gibt aber das ist auch ein relativ das halt einfach auch zieht also weil genauso wie,
in den usa und in europa dann gerne darauf hingewiesen wird dass das virus etwas ausländisches und ein fremdkörper ist und dann eben mit china assoziiert wird zieht es narrativ halt auch in china dann zu sagen es ist etwas was aus dem ausland kommt.
Auf die verschwörungstheorien
kommen wir gleich nochmal mich würde jetzt zum abschluss für woran nochmal interessieren wieso die situation jetzt gerade ist in bezug auf die beschränkung und die kontrollmaßnahme die jetzt noch stattfinden weil es wurde ja viel darüber geredet der lok down ist jetzt vorüber aber dem ist ja mit
nichten so also die einschränkungen sind ja nach wie vor gegeben.
Naja also man kann schon glaube ich wieder einigermaßen irgendwie rumlaufen in der stadt so also es ist schon einigermaßen wieder.
Also dass man schon wieder einigermaßen frei in der stadt rumlaufen kann,
man kann auch zum beispiel wieder man kann auch zum beispiel wieder irgendwie essen gehen und solche sachen es war zwischenzeitlich noch eingeschränkt inwieweit man drinnen in restaurant sitzen kann ich weiß nicht was da jetzt der aktuelle stand ist die leute haben fangen wieder die leute fangen wieder an zu arbeiten.
Aber gleichzeitig ist es glaube ich schon so dass manche und auch zum beispiel wohnkomplex die lange niemandem reingelassen hat den ich in der wohnkomplex wohnt haben sich wieder geöffnet also es ist glaube ich so.
Soweit ich das aus der pferde beurteilen kann.
Wird es schon langsam wieder relativ normal ich glaube es gibt schon noch so ein paar grundsätzliche vorsichtsmaßnahmen aber diese wirklich enormen einschränkungen gibt es sollte das beurteilen kann nicht mehr.
Aber so veranstaltungen et cetera das dürfte wahrscheinlich eh nicht beschränkt sein wie bei uns.
Das habe ich noch nichts gehört.
Dann machen wir doch vielleicht mal kurz ein schritt in ein nachbarland was du ja auch,
kennst nämlich total waren waren ist ja jetzt insofern interessant nicht nur weil es jetzt geographisch nahe ist sondern als auch generell chinesisch ist weil es ja bekanntermaßen eine
demokratisch gewählte regierung hat sie generell in so einer feines beziehung zu china steht aber eben auch über die ganzen industrie produktionsgeschehen
trotzdem eng verbunden ist also vor allem durch den handel reisen et cetera taiwan hat ja dann relativ schnell reagiert,
wie wie ist diese ganze geschichte so in taiwan abgelaufen.
Enorm schnell reagiert ein eine eine notiz am rande es ist.
Schwierig zu sagen taiwan ist chinesisch also das da kann man doch mal selber viel darüber reden aber es ist sehr politisches statement dass so einfach glaube ich nicht mehr stimmt.
Also ich meinte damit taiwan ist ja sozusagen von chinesen auch sozusagen also es sind ja im wesentlichen leute die teilweise aus dem main land kam,
ich weiß nicht genau wie der vermischung ist es wird chinesisch gesprochen das meinte ich.
Genau also genau das ist es nur wichtig so ein bisschen drauf geachtet wird das eine sehr politische aussage ist weil,
unter der kommandant die dort lange reagiert hat war es es gibt viele leute die schon mit ihren familien deutlich länger in taiwan sind,
und wirklich taiwanesischen kultur wurde lange unterdrückt und diese identität als telefonisch zu sein und das ist etwas was jetzt wieder möglich ist seit es an der demokratie ist deswegen ist es genau es ist nur etwas wo man.
Es ist kompliziert aber genau also hat wirklich enorm schnell reagiert also ich hatte eben schon gesagt das ende.
Dezember zum ersten mal so ein bisschen offiziell in china anerkannt wurde dass es diese fälle vielleicht gibt und zum gleichen zeitpunkt hat taiwan direkt angefangen leute die aus wuhan nach taiwan gekommen sind schon zu überprüfen somit fieber messungen und so.
Also es ist noch nicht ganz klar warum also stiefelchen esstische die italienische regierung hat glaube ich gesagt dass sie es gemacht haben weil sie verfolgt haben.
Also dass sie wirklich selber beobachtet haben wo beim netz in china geredet wird
und dass sie wirklich versucht haben von überall irgendwie informationen zu sammeln und als sie dann als dann langsam klar wurde dass es sowas zu geben scheint haben sie gesagt okay wir fangen wir gehen wir leiten dann jetzt sofort maßnahmen ein um das irgendwie,
zu überblicken.
Obwohl taiwan eben auch keine kein direkten zugriff auf informationen aus china hat oder so haben sie das dann quasi also es sind im endeffekt alles open source materials gewesen also ein bisschen open source intelligence quasi.
Das heißt sie haben wenn ein flugzeug aus ankam ich glaube ab dem einunddreißigsten dezember oder ab dem ersten januar haben sie bei allen leuten fieber gemessen,
kurz mit leuten geredet ob sie wie krank sind oder so.
Zum gleichen zeitpunkt etwa als china dann offiziell gesagt hat okay hier ist eine ist ein virus wir müssen uns darum kümmern hat tatsächlich auch taiwan dann ein kommando zentrum eingerichtet schon im januar,
sie haben dann am zwanzigsten januar sie haben dann auch relativ schnell reisen aus china also erst reisen aus wuhan und dann reisen aus china komplett verboten.
Um quasi zu verhindern dass das virus aus china nachteil ankommt weil der unterschied zwischen taiwan und china ist halt dass china in china war das virus da und es hat es gab diesen ausbruch in woran.
Und taiwan wollte halt auf biegen und musste halt auf bio und brechen verändern dass das virus in das land reinkommt und deswegen haben sie halt relativ schnell mit diesen grenzschließungen angefangen.
Und sie haben aber gleichzeitig auch zum beispiel also im januar schon geguckt okay wie viele masken haben wir eigentlich bei uns im land.
Und haben dann relativ schnell exporte von masken ins ausland verboten weil sie gesagt haben okay wir haben nicht genug,
gerade um unsere eigene bevölkerung regelmäßig zur versorgung dann sehr schnell angefangen masken zu rationieren also jede person hat dann irgendwie so drei oder fünf masken pro woche gekriegt und dann haben sie halt auch die produktion im inland krass hochgefahren also da wurde sehr schnell wirklich sehr viele ressourcen und sehr viele kapazitäten
draufgeworfen dieses problem von verschiedenen seiten so ein bisschen anzugehen.
Das krasse daran war ich war selber in taiwan als das alles passiert ist also ich habe den großteil des januars dort verbracht ich bin aus dem vierundzwanzigsten zurück nach berlin geflogen.
Man hat davon nichts also man hat wirklich von wirklich wenig gemerkt also so zum ende hin,
als ich noch da war so um den zwanzigsten rum einundzwanzigsten rum fing die leute da zu sorgen zu machen und als ich am vierundzwanzigsten geflogen bin war hatten wirklich alle leute im flughafen auch masken auf um quasi sich und andere zu schützen aber es
da war es auch alles so relativ normal das heißt diese ganzen,
also die regierung hat extrem soweit man das bisher gut haben kann wo ich extrem kompetent gearbeitet aber es auch geschafft panik zu verhindern.
Wo bist du denn hin geflogen.
Ich bin von nach berlin geflogen.
Und hier dann sozusagen in so 'ne welt die so groß ist da was.
Es war richtig krass also es war total weil ich bin heute paris umgestiegen und ich hatte auch im flugzeug die meisten leute also es ist halt.
Die meisten die meisten asiatisches aussehen und leute hatten masken auf und die meisten leute also die meisten weißen menschen in diesem flugzeug hatten,
keine masken und dann sind wir halt irgendwie aber in paris aus diesem flugzeug raus und wann hat auf einmal einen flughafen dem und uns alle blöd angeguckt haben weil wir mit masken aus diesem flugzeug ausgestiegen sind.
Das war schon pizza und es gab halt so warnschilder von wegen so ja das sind das sind die symptome aber wo ich mich halt auch schon gewundert habe ich gesagt habe okay ich komme jetzt aus taiwan.
Da gibt's doch offiziell irgendwie gab es vielleicht einen falls du zeit bruder gar keine aber das hat dann auch an der grenze dass man den.
Ich finde es schon komisch dass man da nicht mal irgendwie gefragt wird so ja okay sie kommen aus der region wo waren sie irgendwie ich war auch ein paar tage vorher noch in hongkong gewesen für ein paar tage.
Das war schon komisch irgendwie dass man da nicht mehr irgendwie darauf angesprochen wurde oder so ja sehr merkwürdiges gefühl.
Ja bei mir vorstellen.
Sowas wird auch bis in den märz rein noch also ich habe das mehrfach mitgekriegt von leuten die aus china nach deutschland zurückgekommen sind halt auf direktflüge gesagt haben mit frankfurt wurde halt gesagt diese sollten aufpassen aber so das war's dann.
Es ist doch schon sehr bizarre gefühl.
Ich meine merkt man einfach dass wir damit einfach überhaupt gar keine erfahrung haben und kultureller vermutlich auch noch nicht richtig aufgestellt gewesen wäre weil
hätte ja jetzt niemanden groß weh getan wenn da jetzt eine armada von leuten gestanden hätte die zumindest mal überall mal so eine fieber messung macht also es gibt ja diese
infrarot messer das da muss man ja keinem jetzt irgendwas in popo stecken von daher,
wäre das ein relativ günstig verkaufter vorsprung gewesen aber wir wissen ja alle dass es nun anders kam und das insbesondere an
wahrscheinlich auch zu diesem zeitpunkt italien eben besonders,
betroffen war gerade weil's da relativ intensive wirtschaftsbeziehungen gibt beziehungsweise viele leute glaube ich auch aus china in italien arbeiten gearbeitet haben und.
Dadurch ist dieser injektion kam.
Also das das mit den inwieweit die wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit china wie in italien dafür verantwortlich waren ist noch nicht also ich habe da noch nichts schlüssiges wirklich darüber gelesen und es ist auch wieder so ein bisschen vorsichtig sein muss weil das natürlich ein sehr.
Auf anhieb ist es ein sehr schlüssiges und bequem ist negativ irgendwie,
aber ich habe zum beispiel mit einem italienischen kollegen über das thema gesprochen der auch zu china arbeitete der gesagt hat dass die ganzen leute die leute die aus china gekommen sind haben sich selber teils quantifiziert und sind selber enorm vorsichtig.
Ja ich wollte gar nicht sagen dass es jetzt so sein die chinesen waren die ist da hingetragen haben die wirtschaftlichen beziehungen ist ja immer wieder regional kann er sehr wohl auch die italiener gewesen sein die sich halt einfach mal abgeholt haben und dann ohne maske in die bevölkerung getragen haben weiß ich nicht ob das überhaupt
sich nochmal klären lässt ist halt jetzt so wie es ist.
Ich glaube eine ein wichtiger aspekt hat sich auch noch gerettet hat und ich glaube eine wichtige sache ist auch noch wie sehr die erfahrung mit saß wirklich
die leute geprägt hat also ich kriege das in hongkong mit china und auch in taiwan ich hatte mit jemandem von der termine machen also deren solchen bekämpfung behörde gesprochen und der hatte gesagt so ein bisschen so.
Mehr oder weniger ja wir wussten nicht was es war wasser aus wie saß und wir haben dann erstmal es so behandelt als sei es neuer saß ausbruch.
Also es gab quasi das heißt die haben das einmal durchgemacht das sind wirklich viele leute im gesundheitssystem gestorben in taiwan und die haben dann als sie das wieder gesehen haben hat die regierung das erfolgreich sein okay wir machen das jetzt einfach so als sei es saß.
Das heißt er war sofort also wirklich relativ schnell allerhöchste alarmstufe und in ich glaube das ist auch das wo du wie du halt sagt ist das.
Diese erfahrung hier vielleicht so ein bisschen fehlt und das ist auch nicht unbedingt irgendwie einen plan dafür gibt was dann gemacht werden soll,
wobei man gleichzeitig auch sagen muss dass in taiwan auch einfach die strategie immer wieder und sehr schnell angepasst wurde also dass sie auch relativ schnell auf sich eine wandel wandelnde situation reagiert haben und.
Das ist sicherlich eine dass der erfahrung zuzuschreiben aber sie waren einfach auch immer wieder sehr flexibel und haben sich im zweifel immer angepasst.
Ja ich hab's gerade mal nachgeschlagen also es wird davon ausgegangen dass bei der saß emie zweitausendzwei war das ja ein geschäftsmann der von.
Hongkong oder zurückreisen nach taiwan das ins land geschleppt hat.
Erfahrung hilft ja immer,
war gerade in letzter zeit sehr viel von der who und der beziehung zu taiwan die rede und dass die who ja hier sehr weiß ich nicht wie man das nennen soll aber irgendwie,
viel einfluss durch china erhält also durch mailand china erhalten hat wie was was was geht da ab was was ist da das ding.
Ich kann die interne politik der nicht so gut beurteilen aber die who scheint schon sich sehr viel mühe geradezu geben nicht wütend zu machen.
Und also es ist ja mit china und taiwans ein bisschen kompliziert also einmal so kurz schameless plug wir haben kürzlich eine fernost folge gemacht dazu warum startest du kompliziert ist und was daran,
das würde ich wirklich empfehlen weil es wirklich sehr verworren ist aber im wesentlichen ist es so dass bis in die frühen siebziger jahre taiwan offiziell als china anerkannt wurde international und auch als china in der saß.
Dann neunzehnhundert ich glaube einundsiebzig war das wurde taiwan dieser status aberkannt und stattdessen hat die die volksrepublik anerkannt.
Die who ist eine internationale organisation in der nur staaten teilnehmen dürfen die auch in der un sitzen das heißt mit seinem sitz hat taiwan eben auch seinen sitz in der wm verloren.
Taiwan könnte als beobachter noch mitmachen aber das ist etwas was von den mitgliedern.
Abgestimmt werden muss und zweitausendsechzehn hat taiwan seinen beobachter status verloren den es von zweitausendneun bis zweitausendsiebzehn glaube ich hatte.
Das ist ich genau ich kann tatsächlich nicht beurteilen wie viel davon direkt chinesischer einfluss ist und wie viel davon.
Also was genau wie genau dieser anschluss dort funktioniert aber es ist relativ offensichtlich dass die auf biegen und brechen versucht china zu verärgern es gab zum beispiel irgendwie kürzlich fall wo eine hongkong und journalistin.
Ein vertreter interview interviewt hat und dann gefragt hat.
Ihm irgendwas zu taiwan gefragt hat also ich glaube ob die angesichts von taiwan erfolgreicher antiko wird strategie vielleicht nochmal überdenken würde.
Aber nicht doch an der teilnehmen sollte oder ob man mit hermann redet und so und das ist wirklich unheimlich peinlich weil dieser mann hat dann so getan als hätte er die frage nicht gehört.
Hat sie nochmal gefragt.
Und dann hat er aufgelegt sind skype-call einfach beendet und hat sie nochmal angerufen gesagt können wir dann nochmal über meine frage reden dann meinte er ja wir haben schon über china geredet lass uns jetzt mal weitermachen.
Also total total bezahl und die who lässt auch zum beispiel china taiwans fälle als seine fälle mit melden weil eben.
Das gar nicht in die statistik eingeht sozusagen.
Genau also china sagt quasi eine provinz chinas und deswegen.
Berichten wie das mit wir haben halt nur gerade keine kontrolle über diese provinz aber es ist eine unserer provinzen so es ist quasi die offizielle position und also
und es ist auch so also dass die who es gibt wo so einen es gibt so ein memorandum das quasi reguliert was die wir hier quasi machen darf mit bezug zur china
morandi sagt für dass die rechtlich nichts machen darf was den status taiwans als land anerkennen könnte das heißt es kann halt auch also das ist offensichtlich also das ist wohl
so ein rechtlicher zwang so jessica dran das ist eine politik wissenschaftlerin die sehr viel zu taiwan arbeitet hatte darüber geschrieben und.
Also ich gehe davon aus dass dann zum beispiel dieses,
gesprächs deswegen zustande gekommen ist weil dann dieser arzt da saß und er so art scheiße was mache ich jetzt ach du scheiße ich lege jetzt einfach auf und tu so als ob nichts passiert ist,
offiziell darf die who aber mit der regierung taiwans zusammenarbeiten wenn es ein gesundheits- fall gibt und man könnte meinen dass eine globale pandemien dazugehört und es gibt jetzt auch durchaus also so langsam.
Bisschen druck taiwan wieder seinen beobachter status zurückzugeben also australien wird sich wohl soweit ich das,
jetzt heute richtig gelesen habe offiziell hinter die forderung stellen dass terror wieder in der who mitmachen darf weil momentan ist teilweise einfach komplett ausgeschlossen von diesen ganzen sachen.
Das war auch bei saß schon ein problem.
Es gab zum beispiel berichtet dass taiwan erst sehr spät zugang zu zum beispiel sequenzen des virus hatte weil es halt von diesen ganzen von diesen kooperationen innerhalb der who ausgeschlossen worden war.
Und auch diesen ganzen meetings und zu welchem planungs- und dann einfach nicht hingehen kann weil also sie dürfen sie dürfen halt einfach nicht und werden einfach komplett das wird komplett gemauert und es ist halt schwer zu sagen.
Man man gewinnt zu müssen den eindruck in den letzten monaten dass die who generell nicht so eine schreckliche effiziente organisation ist.
Und sie glaube ich auch wie so viele internationale organisationen ihren mitgliedern gern gegenüber zu sanktionen hat was ihr generell so ein problem ist im internationalen recht,
das heißt es ist natürlich auch es ist natürlich auch nicht klar wie sehr sich das jetzt geändert hätte wenn die who mittelmann gesprochen hätte ob dann ihre empfehlung wie deutlich besser gewesen wäre oder so
aber man muss schon sagen dass die taiwanesischen strategie einfach also erfolgreich war und das teil waren einfach nie an den punkt gekommen ist indem wir zum beispiel gerade in deutschland sind,
einfach erfolgreich verhindert haben dass es virus ins land gekommen ist.
Nicht nur das jetzt aber auch mit ihrer massenproduktion etcetera in der lage ist den rest der welt hier auch mit entsprechenden materialien zu versorgen und vor allem die wirtschaft nicht hat abwirken müssen.
Ja genau ich glaube das ist einfach ein sehr wichtiger ein sehr wichtiger punkt also es gab.
Ich habe einen text über ich habe einen text über korea gelesen wo ein koreanische jura-professor gesagt hat dass jedes jedes land.
Gewisse freiheiten aufgeben.
Werden muss um diese panik zu werden und den taiwan wurde sich eben dafür entschieden diese relativ krassen restriktionen für die einreise einzuführen.
Es wird auch eine relativ strikte quarantäne,
so ein forst also sowohl für leute die aus dem ausland zurückkommen als auch für leute die engen kontakt mit einem bestätigten fall hatten also da wird das signal von,
oder es wird benutzt um die telefonie die den standort der telefone von leuten zu überwachen die in so einer quarantäne sind.
Um sicher zu gehen dass sie wirklich nicht rausgehen und das ist eben wirklich also diese gesamte,
macht wird darauf forciert zu verhindern dass es virus ins land kommt und es ist so ein bisschen so ist halt so ein trader weil,
im ausland habe ich das zwerchfell mitgekriegt dass leute sagen ah das ist ein krasser überwachungsstaat in die leute werden der mittlere überwacht das ist voll übel und so aber wenn ich mit leuten in taiwan rede dann sagen also für viele freundinnen von mir ist dann halt so.
Viele von denen mussten diese zweiwöchige quarantäne auch machen die halt aus dem weil sie teil zum ausland studieren.
Die sagen ja ich war dann halt zwei wochen eine quarantäne ein ein freund von mir meinte so ja ich habe dann ich habe gegessen geschlafen und bin fett geworden,
aber jetzt danach können sie halt wieder ein also ziemlich normales,
ziemlich normalen alltag eigentlich leben also es gibt natürlich auch keine großveranstaltung und zum beispiel so konzerte und clubs und so gibt es auch einfach gerade nicht
aber man hat auch an diesen google hat ja von einer weile diese diese bewegung daten rausgegeben wurde mir gesehen hat wie sehr die normale aktivität in verschiedenen ländern der welt eingeschränkt wurde,
und taiwan war das land in dem sich das verhalten der menschen an wenigsten verändert hat weil es einfach an dem komplett also was einfach nie diesen ausbruch hat und ich glaube es hat jetzt seit sechs oder sieben tagen.
Ich glaube seit vierzehn tagen kein.
Telefonischen fall mehr gehabt und seit sechs tagen keinen neuen fall mehr also seid ihr seit vierzehn tagen wurden nur noch importierte fälle gemeldet und dann seit sechs tagen einfach gar keinen fall mehr.
Ich komme gerade mal auf die aktuellen mobilitätstraining wie sie sich so abbilden was recht also es gab natürlich ein rückgang aber nicht im ansatz zu vergleichen mit deutschland oder usa
und mittlerweile wird sogar überdurchschnittlich viel gegangen und gefahren und wo der öpnv ist noch um dreißig prozent im keller.
Und aber da auch wiederum wenn man den n v ist es tragen auch da schon seit wochen alle masken also es ist so ganz natürlich es ist ja auch ein taiwan so,
auch in china mache ich auch wenn ich wenn ich krank bin dann setze ich mir halt eine maske auf wenn ich zum beispiel weiß dass ich den ganzen tag mit irgendwelchen anderen leuten in einem klassenzimmer verbringen muss dann ist halt einfach es ist total normal und dass man dann sich eine maske aufsetzt um zu finden dass man andere leute ansteckt.
Da guckt er noch keiner an und das war halt auch schon immer so ne.
Nicht immer so also ich habe.
Also ich kenne es aus japan dass das dass das dass das dort einfach immer schon so etikette auch gehörte also als ich da mal war vor langer zeit.
Ich habe jetzt neulich gehört dass es etwas ist was durch saßen deutlich forciert wurde also das ist quasi eine gewohnheit ist die durch saß erst so richtig.
Okay.
Aber ich kann das historisch selber nicht genau belegen aber es ist auf jeden fall jetzt schon seit langer zeit etwas.
Ja gut ich wollte nicht sagen dass es schon schon seit dreihundert jahren so ist das natürlich nicht ne aber es hat sich dort eben.
Wahrscheinlich durch die durch den viren ausbruch vielfältiger art einfach manifestiert und ich denke jetzt werden wir das in europa auch sehen.
Hoffentlich und ich glaube was wichtig ist ist auch es ist halt auch so ein rucksack ist halt noch ein rücksichtslos ich glaube das ist einfach wichtig dass es halt auch.
Ich glaube das ist etwas was man in deutschland erst gelernt hat jetzt die letzten wochen über das was getragen und was glaube ich auch wie immer noch langsam erst lernen müssen das maske tragen auch ein.
Rücksichtsnahme.
Genau.
Dann lass uns doch mal auf ein anderes verhältnis kommen nämlich dass zwischen china und den usa das war ja nun in den letzten monaten ohnehin schon ziemlich aufgeladen seit trump anfängt da
alle möglichen handelskrieg vom zaun zu brechen und china auch in tausend anderen kontexten für seine machenschaften heranzoomt jetzt ist ja,
shila
auch nicht gerade zurückhaltend was verschiedene maßnahmen in dieser hinsicht betrifft was geht da ab und haben die sich überhaupt noch lieb.
Also definitiv haben sie sich nicht mehr lieb ich habe das jetzt schon mehrfach gehört und ich würde dem auch zustimmen dass leute gesagt haben dass die.
Us chinesischen beziehungen sich an einem tiefpunkt befinden der tiefe ist als die beziehung nach dem massaker auf dem platz ist himmlischen friedens.
Und das ist halt schon eine sehr krasse aussage ich lese man kann das so ein bisschen charakterisieren dass.
In sich in den usa in den letzten fünf jahren vielleicht.
So einen konsens gebildet hat dass man irgendwas china halt irgendwie böse ist wenn man was gegen china zu tun muss und manch einer irgendwie generell nicht trauen kann und das wird dann jetzt eben durch trump auf eine gewisse weise umgesetzt,
es wäre aber auch also selbst wenn hillary clinton gewonnen hätte zweitausendsechzehn hätte auch eine demokratische regierung die us beziehung zur china kalibriert.
Es ist etwas aber trump gemacht hat statt da zu reparieren dass der angefangen ist einfach komplett zu torpedieren einfach auf eine art und weise die.
Den usa selber auch glaube ich wehtut weil zum beispiel der handelskrieg hat halt wirtschaftlich den usa auch sehr geschadet aber soweit ich das gerade beurteilen kann gehabt hat es komplett daran gescheitert irgendwelche.
Wirklich ernsthafte konzessionen von der.
Von der von der chinesischen regierung zu erlangen das heißt also die strategie der trump-regierung scheint sie wissen zu sein so viel draufzuschlagen aber nicht wirklich strategisch zu gucken was man wirklich machen kann um irgendwie wirklich was zu erreichen und das ist so ein bisschen das frustrierende weil es gibt ja durchaus viele.
Themenfelder bei denen man die chinesische regierung eigentlich zur verantwortung ziehen müsste unter anderem zum beispiel diese lager mit den ganzen in shanghai in westin.
Aber bei trump hat man halt eben das gefühl dass ihm so ein bisschen darum geht.
So kurzfristig gesiegelt zu erlangen und dass er sagen kann er macht was gegen china aber das ist nicht wirklich um die substanz geht um dahingehend ist es dann so dass ich jetzt in den letzten.
Die beziehung einfach nach und nach enorm verschlechtert haben und er hat einfach immer und immer wieder drauf haut.
Sich diese länder so ein bisschen voneinander wegbewegen gerade und ich glaube sowohl in also in beiden ländern wird es ist doch etwas was durch so nationalismus noch befeuert wird.
Es es gibt diesen begriff des ich weiß nicht wie bei denen auf deutsch am besten.
Genauso eine entkoppelung der beiden länder über das ist so ein begriff der zunehmend.
Öfter benutzt wird um darüber zu sprechen dass die beiden länder halt versuchen sich einander voneinander so ein bisschen zu entwirren und im endeffekt diese dieses globalisierungsgegner was sie ja lange verbunden hat.
So ein bisschen zu entfernen,
und ich glaube also ich persönlich würde schon sagen dass man sagen kann dass es etwas ist was auf die us initiative hin passiert ist das ist aber auch so also so ein bisschen man kann so ein bisschen sagen,
ich weiß nicht mehr wer das meine ich glaube es waren ausländische korrespondent der gesagt hatte wenn man versucht china so ein also so von unten also so so ein so ein lob love zu versetzen also so richtig dreckig zu kämpfen dann wird china immer nochmal dreckiger zurückschlagen im zweifel.
Und das hat man ganz gut gesehen als die usa angefangen haben.
Wirklich so symbolisch so ein bisschen chinesische staatsmedien als ausländische agenten zu die signieren das war jetzt glaube ich im dezember oder so das ist schon eine ganze weile her,
und dann angefangen haben diesen leuten die dort arbeiten teils die journalismus visa zu entziehen um zu sagen ah ja das ist als so als,
rückzahlung dafür was wir hier mit den ausländischen medien in in china macht und als antwort daraufhin wurden dann mehrere journalist in das wallstreet journals aus china rausgeworfen,
haben die usa chinesische journalistinnen rausgeworfen und china also china dann ah ja wirkt das können wir auch,
und china hat dann glaube ich achtzehn amerikanische journalistinnen also von der new york times dem drin und der washington post.
Rausgeworfen also ist also so ein bisschen ist es geht immer nochmal tiefer.
Wir können wir können dreckiger als ihr ja.
Also ich glaube das ist ein ganz gut also ich glaube das ist ein ganz gutes beispiel dafür was für eine strategie trump pferd also so ein bisschen so einfach immer draufhauen ohne strategie.
Das problem ist wenn man solche sachen macht also china hat ja die chinesische regierung hat kein problem damit noch mehr leute nochmal journalistinnen rauszuschmeißen so.
Gleichzeitig ist es aber natürlich so.
In den usa ist jetzt zum beispiel so dass zunehmend einfach auch chinesisch studierende unter generalverdacht gestellt werden also es ist so ein bisschen diese idee gibt's alle chinesische studierenden spione für die regierung sind,
oder dass leute die ursprünglich aus china kommen die ganzen geheimnisse stehlen,
zum beispiel total verkennt dass wir achtzig prozent oder so von chinesischen studierenden die in den usa die machen auch im land bleiben und dort arbeiten langfristig die leute wollen ja in den usa leben wenn sie jetzt halt einfach total krass angefeindet,
man kann dann sagen okay,
die chinesische regierung verliert wenig wenn sie also auch so ein zunehmenden rassismus und so oder ist eigentlich rassismus ist eher so ein so ein zunehmendes bist trauen gegenüber ausländern zulässt aber die usa verlieren ja enorm weil sie ja für sich behaupten.
Für diese demokratische ideal zu stehen das heißt auf diesem niveau dann auf diesem niveau zu kämpfen tut ihnen eigentlich also,
würde ich sagen tut ihr eigentlich nur noch mehr weh weil,
gerade auch chinesische studierende in den usa die das mitbekommen die sind ja nicht blöd und die sehen das dann und also die kommen dann aus china in die usa,
die sagen ach ja ihr versucht uns zu erzählen dass ihr so eine geile demokratie seid und diese ganzen ideale hochhaltet aber ihr beschuldigt mich dass ich ein spion bin nur weil ich so nur weil ich.
Zufällig in china geboren wurde und jetzt gerne in einem anderen land studieren würde so das ist also so kann man glaube ich.
Es wurden sehr viele eigentore erzielt auf seiten der usa in den letzten jahren und so gewinnt man auch keine leute für seine seite so ein bisschen.
Das problem hat die usa ja nicht nur mit china ich denke das ist ein globaler trend der sich ja mittlerweile sogar auch in,
in europa abzeichnet langfristig ist er bestimmt mit einem bestimmten brain drain zu rechnen das land ist auch an sich
unattraktiver geworden durch die zustände dort und ich glaube das werden wir dann erst so in den verlauf der nächsten zehn jahre so richtig ablesen können wie nachhaltig das ganze ist man sieht es die kappe.
Ist natürlich eine generelle frage die jetzt denke ich auch.
Wenn sie jetzt mal auf die globalisierung an sich also die globalisierung der der wirtschaft mal vom tourismus nochmal abgesehen sehr,
sich ohnehin vielen ländern stellt wir hatten ja jetzt auch gerade diskussion um die versorgung mit basismedikamente wo heute ein großteil aus china und eben aus indien geliefert wird wo es hier teilweise gar keine
dafür gibt man aber eben auch sieht wenn die länder jetzt sagen okay das ist aber jetzt mal hier unser bedarf na so ein bisschen wie teilweise die masken okay.
Überall herstellen na aber wenn auf einmal so eine eine ressource auf die man sich verlassen hat einfach mal so von heute auf morgen wegfällt dann merkt man eben sehr schnell dass diese ganzen global vernetzten produktionskette,
einiges abschneiden und das ist dann eben sofort eine große auswirkung hat auf das können wir unsere tests hier gar nicht mehr durchführen weil uns fehlt hier irgendein,
lächerlicher basis stoff er hat die problemlos selber herstellen können die mir aus kostengründen weil es eben fünf cent billiger ist eben jetzt einfach aus dem ausland holen.
Genau das ist natürlich auch eine also es ist natürlich eine langfristige frage so ist es,
also einerseits ist es dieses ganze immer alles effizienter machen wo der halt in der vergangenheit immer forciert und und das haben die andere frage ist dann quasi die antwort darauf jetzt so einen komischen nationalismus zu fahren wo man sagt wir müssen alles irgendwie zuhause,
america haben das ist halt einfach es ist es ist es schwierig und es ist auch ein es ist eine schwierige frage auf die ist glaube ich keine einfachen antworten gibt.
Wir sind die perspektive chinas jetzt auf
europa also europa verhält sich ja ein bisschen anders steht aber im prinzip jetzt genauso mit runter gelassenen hosen da
was dieses narrativ mit chinesischer virus etcetera betrifft gut das wurde jetzt hier nicht so ausgeschlachtet aber natürlich hat man lange zeit das ganze eben auch als ein chinesisches problem angesehen und meine wahrnehmung ist so ein bisschen dass man sich dann doch schon ein wenig jetzt
na ja ich weiß nicht vielleicht die die bäuche hält aber dann schon sich so ein bisschen so ein
eine eine meinung einstellt mit so naja ihr großkopferten westler blickt immer so ein bisschen auf uns herab und jetzt seht ihr mal was ihr davon habt.
Also ich würde schon sagen die frage ist immer so ein bisschen man muss sich immer so ein bisschen fragen wo wo gibt es diese,
dieser ansicht aber ich habe schon das gefühl dass das so ein bisschen gibt und das wird natürlich auch durch dieses narrativ der regierung stark forciert was ich eben schon,
hatte das halt jetzt gerade sehr gerne darauf hingewiesen wird wie wie viel schlimmer ist jetzt in europa ist als es in china ist und,
in vielen teilen der bevölkerung zieht das also annette es gibt halt nie gute umfragen das ist immer das problem ein spekuliert einfach immer sehr viel das heißt wenn man so öffentliche meinung beurteilt dann ist man immer sehr
durch den eigenen bikes beeinflusst zum beispiel darüber wo man seine eigene mit wie man redet mit wem man kontakt hat so und die meisten leute die ich kenne
sind halt irgendwie sehr internationale junge menschen die auch irgendwie mehrere andere sprache noch sprechen auf die zeit im ausland verbracht haben und selbst die schauen gerade fassungslos nach europa und sagen so wach du scheiße was macht ihr denn da.
Andere nehmen das dann halt so dieses propaganda narrativ mit auf und sagen dann ja okay ist dann doch ganz geil und ich traue jetzt der regierung mehr aber auch also auch leute die halt.
Die man nicht vorwerfen kann dass sie nicht kritisch denken würden oder so schauen halt jetzt rüber und sagen ok ihr hättet das eigentlich besser wissen müssen.
Und natürlich gibt es dann so ein bisschen ich glaube auch in europa gibt es natürlich auch was weniger in europa forciert wird was in den usa sehr forciert das ist diese.
Ist der vorwurf an china das weil sie es halt so lange runtergespielt haben dass deswegen das virus jetzt so schlimm ist.
Ich habe das gefühl dass wir nicht so krass forciert in europa aber es ist ja schon tatsächlich so dass in china.
Also dass die leute relativ viele opfer gebracht haben relativ früh und dass jetzt auch viele leute die ich kenne nicht verstehen warum dann in europa nichts gemacht wurde also die dann sagen so hey ich war.
Drei monate zu hause und hab mich nicht quasi nicht bewegt weil ich glaube weil ich wusste wir müssen jetzt dieses opfer bringen und danach wird's dann besser.
Und gleichzeitig sehen sie dann jetzt in europa das irgendwie teils leute rausgehen trotzdem und sagen so hey was geht denn also warum habe ich das gemacht wenn ihr jetzt nicht auch könnt so wie kann man so verantwortungslos sein so ein bisschen.
Also es gab ja in deutschland zwischenzeitlich immer so berichtet dass es dieses obere limit von tausend leuten für veranstaltungen gehabt dass der mehrere konzerte gesagt haben sie lassen genau neunhundertneunundneunzig leute rein und einer dieser fälle sind china viral gegangen also das war ein riesiger skandal,
im chinesischen letztes leute gesagt haben was also das kann doch nicht wahr sein dass dass man so wie kann man so verantwortungslos sein.
Denkst du das so verantwortung spüren für die gesellschaft in in china meeren ding ist als bei uns dass sie dieser individualismus stärker ist als ein,
vielleicht existieren da kollektivismus oder ist das eine falsche wahrnehmung.
Ist es schwierig also so aus politik wissenschaftlicher sicht gibt es zum beispiel viel es gibt zum beispiel forschung zu,
zu gesellschaftlichen vertrauen und ich glaube wenn man manchmal gelebt hat dann kriegt man mit dass so das vertrauen gegenüber anderen menschen die man nicht kennt es eher sehr niedrig also es gibt ein sehr hohes misstrauen gegenüber fremden,
und die leute haben auch nicht unbedingt das gefühl dass den leuten die uns gegenüber irgendwie eine verantwortung haben oder so.
Aber was sehr viel also wo es deutlich deutlich stärkere verbindung gibt dass zum beispiel innerhalb des eigenen sozialen kreises dann also so sozialer soziales vertrauen gegenüber leuten die einem nahestehen es ist höher.
Das heißt es ist deutlich komplizierter als nur so kollektivismus gegen individualismus zu sagen und es ist auch nicht und eine sache die auch es ist halt auch viele leute die ich kenne sind halt auch,
von alleine drin geblieben auch als auch wenn restriktion nicht so stark waren aber es gibt auch natürlich in china super viele berichte von leuten die sich hier diese ganzen sachen gehalten haben
das ist halt auch einer der gründe warum sich das virus halt weiter verbreitet hat weil den die leute sich nicht an die quarantäne gehalten haben oder weil leute es gab es gab einen fall von einer chinesin,
die propheten genommen hat und dann mit corona virus nach paris geflogen ist und total stolz darauf war dass sie diese fieber messen thermometer,
vermieden hat so also es gibt halt solche und solche und es ist ich kann es wirklich es ist wirklich sehr schwierig festzumachen.
Wo woher das kommt und ich also es ist wirklich.
Zum beispiel in taiwan gibt es das ja auch während des zum beispiel das in japan wieder weniger gibt also wenn ich mit freunden aus japan spreche die sagen eher naja die leute hier verhalten sich eher unvernünftig.
Von der ist es sehr schwierig festzumachen was das wirklich dann so treibt und was es auch gesamtgesellschaftlich.
Ich denke das lässt sich auch nicht so so einfach auf so eine achse abtragen es ist da schon dann eine etwas mehr dimensionale matrix weil wir haben ja so eine ähnliche debatte auch jetzt gerade im verhältnis zu schweden
ja jetzt wissen wir dass das das schweden wie die meisten skandinavischen ländern
schweden wenn ich es richtig sehe oder mich auch echt kein experte ist es vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen ausgeprägter so ein extrem trust level auch gegenüber der regierung haben oder sagen wir mal der der gesamtgemeinde schaft gegenüber sodass diese wahrnehmung in schweden würde ja jetzt ein fair gelten
so auch nicht zu halten ist sondern dass es vermutet es bewege mich jetzt hier wirklich aus wie auf dünnem eis ist so ein bisschen meine wahrnehmung dass man sieht
ja es gibt zwar nicht so stark
beschlossene maßnahmen und vorgaben für ein look down aber die empfehlungen die wiederum gegeben werden werden dann auch automatisch besser umgesetzt weil das eben,
so ist
ja also weil das das das gesellschaftliche gefüge schneller annimmt während wir hier in deutschland geradezu darauf warten
dass wir dann was verboten bekommen dann ist auch dann dann ist auch okay so also,
abgesehen jetzt von diesen verschwörungstheoretikern sogenannten freiheitskämpfern ja also man man man willst dann auch verboten bekommen weil dann dann
dann ist es halt so und dann wissen wir auch dann gilt sie halt auch für alle aber es braucht eben auch diesen akt also es ist.
Glaube ich ein interessantes feld hier auch nochmal für die soziologische forschung für die nächsten jahre heraus zu knobeln was jetzt hier eigentlich die entscheidenden faktoren waren.
Ich glaube es ist auch das ist auch tatsächlich eine interessante frage weil ich manchmal auf die demokratie und zum beispiel korea oder taiwan schau und mir wünschte wir werden hier ein bisschen eher so weil es ist tatsächlich ja nicht so dass die leute dort einfach generell machen was ihr regierung ihnen sagt also will
hongkong zum beispiel auch also es gibt in hongkong jetzt seit monaten proteste in,
taiwan haben zweitausendvierzehn studierende gegen ein handelsabkommen mit china demonstriert und das parlament besetzt und die letzte koreanische präsidentin wurde abgesetzt weil es massenproteste geben sie gab also es ist halt wirklich es ist wirklich,
taiwan und südkorea einfach lebendige gesunde demokratien und protest findet statt aber halt es hat sich nicht sowas reflexhaft es irgendwie.
Und ich glaube das ist einfach schon so dass diese also auch so vorgaben einfach befolgt werden weil die leute das auch für sinnvoll erachten und die sagen okay ja das macht sinn ich verstehe warum wir das machen sollen und dann.
Machen wir das.
Weil du angesprochen hast ziehe ich das mal kurz vor situation in hongkong ist ja auch nochmal so ein interessanter chinesischer
teil ich habe jetzt hier bei auch schon zwei sendungen die sich jetzt mit den protesten dort und diesem dieser schleichenden übernahme hongkong durch china beschäftigt haben ich habe jetzt nicht so viel mitbekommen aber man gewinnt schon so den eindruck
dass die regierung in hongkong diese auszeit diese protest auszeit diese erzwungene auch so zu ihrem vorteil nutzt.
Absolut also es wurde jetzt gerade von vor ich glaube vor zwei wochen wurden vor der verein zwei wochen wurden fünfzehn mindestens fünfzehn.
Alt demokraten also so alt aktivistinnen der demokratischen bewegung festgenommen.
Und es werden jetzt auch gerade wieder langsam es werden jetzt auch gerade wieder langsam diese gerichtsverfahren angestoßen also die mehrere verfahren gegen leute wegen aufstand,
wurden jetzt angestoßen das ist ein,
das ist ein tatbestand aus der kolonialzeit auf denen es bis zu zehn jahre haft gibt also man auch sehr schön sieht dass du der alte und der neue kolonialismus stehen in einander greifen also
um gegen gegen diese proteste gegen die chinesische zugänglichen dieses übernahme vorzugehen wird ein gesetz benutzt das noch unter den briten in der kulinarik seit geschrieben wurde um gegen leute vorzugehen die gegen.
Die kolonialisierung waren das heißt geht so hand in hand und deswegen haben wir jetzt die proteste aber auch wieder angefangen also.
Hongkong ist auch ein gutes beispiel dafür dass es eben nicht nur unbedingt auf die regierung ankommt also ich soweit ich die hongkong,
reaktion beurteilen kann was relativ kompetent aber sie haben sich sehr lange dagegen gewehrt die reisen aus china zu einzuschränken.
In hongkong war es aber so dass sehr schnell dann quasi diese ganzen diese ganze mobilisierung die es halt gab für die proteste im endeffekt genutzt wurde um gegen kuvert neunzehn zu mobilisieren und um zu mobilisieren und die regierung dazu zu bringen.
Mehr gegen das virus zu tun das heißt das hat glaube ich auch relativ effektiv funktioniert ist halt sehr schnell so eine so eine gemeinschaft und so eine community response dazu gab,
und das heißt aber auch das bloß weil jetzt ist ein paar monate lang keine großen proteste gab,
diese netzwerke nicht tot sind weil das halt netzwerker waren die die ganze zeit weiter aktiv waren aber die halt benutzt wurden um zu mobilisieren um zum beispiel die angestellten des gesundheitssystems zu unterstützen,
und jetzt bitte diese netzwerke video zurückgegriffen um wieder forciert so ging also die mehr also diese forderung nach demokratie.
Durchzusetzen und leute zusammenzubringen um zum beispiel gegen diese festnahmen zu demonstrieren.
Und hat das auch erfolg oder ist das jetzt ja nur noch nicht tot.
Es ist es ist echt schwer zu beurteilen so also ich denke.
Man muss der hongkonger bewegung einfach zu gut erhalten dass sie jetzt seit einem jahr bald auf die straße geht und.
Es ist aber tatsächlich auch einfach so dass sie wirklich wenig erfolge zu verzeichnen haben
also sie haben es wurde sie haben geschafft dass es auslieferung zusatz zurückgenommen wurde aber währenddessen weiter sich der politische einfluss der chinesischen regierung in hongkong einfach deutlich wetter aus auch also die offizielle vertretung der chinesischen regierung
in hongkong hat auch in den letzten tag und wochen immer mal wieder so sachen gesagt wo sie von im sinne von dass sie nicht glauben dass sie sich irgendwie groß an die gesetze halten müssen und dass sie
so sehen dass sie relativ großen einfluss nehmen dürfen und so ist das sehr umstritten ist und auch rechtlich fraglich ist und.
Also das ist es ist schwierig ich glaube man kann halt sagen es ist ein erfolg dass die dass diese protestbewegung immer noch existiert also ich war auch selber im januar noch mal auf einem protest um mir das mal anzuschauen und.
Um zu gucken wieso die stimmung ist so ein bisschen und ich glaube es ist.
Im januar war so ein bisschen identitätsfindung angesagt in der protestbewegung also viele leute waren einfach sehr erschöpft auch wegen dieser uni besetzung es hatte im januar einen großen protest gegeben.
Aber die leute versuchen auch vorsichtiger zu sein also daran dass jetzt nicht mehr riesenmassen auf die straße gegangen sind zu so im dezember januar das lag auch unter anderem daran dass die leute angefangen haben darüber nachzudenken wie sie sich selber quasi.
Besser schützen können weil sie gesagt haben es ist auch nicht nachhaltig wenn wir jetzt einfach uns alle der polizei entgegen werfen weil letztendlich der staat einfach deutlich mehr ressourcen hat,
die er uns entgegensetzen kann so dass die leute haben angefangen okay mehr auf sich selber aufzupassen und nicht mehr jede woche auf dem protest zu gehen um halt zu sagen okay ich muss halt auch auf mich selber achten weil niemandem
damit gedient ist wenn ich dann wie bernhard habe und dass die leute auch zunehmend sehen okay es ist auch nicht nachhaltig wenn wir uns alle einfach zu tausenden festnehmen lassen also das muss man sich auf augen halten es wurden jetzt seit märz zweitausendneunzehn wurden insgesamt,
etwa achttausend leute festgenommen im rahmen dieser proteste und der großteil davon.
Ja also festgenommen und die stehen wenn es nach und nach vor gericht gestellt so also tausend verfahren wurden mittlerweile eingeleitet.
Aber das sind ganz viele junge leute die inhalt nicht nochmal auf die straße gehen weil wenn sie halt nochmal festgenommen werden dann hilft es halt ihren fällen nicht und auch wenn jemand festgenommen wurde und dann sagen die freundinnen in denen auch contest nicht mehr mit uns demonstrieren geht wenn du nochmal festgenommen ist dann sitzt du richtig in der scheiße.
Und das sind größtenteils wirklich junge leute irgendwie so unter dreißig die viel noch vor sich haben und jetzt halt
darauf warten dass das justizsystem so langsam sich um ihre fälle kümmert dass die im zweifeln freispruch kriegen und aber das heißt die ganz viele von denen befinden sich halt in so monate bis jahrelang limbo weil das,
die gerichte sich jetzt so ganz langsam diese tausenden von fällen durcharbeiten müssen wo es ganz oft einfach auch wirklich nicht viel beweise geben kann
weil teils junge menschen einfach dafür festgenommen wurden dass sie schwarze sachen an hatten und sich irgendwo am falschen zur falschen zeit am falschen ort befanden.
Von daher ist es schwer zu ist ich glaube die den wandel den man jetzt sieht ist dass die protestbewegung jetzt gerade versucht herauszufinden wie sie sich von einer bewegung die viele menschen in kurzer zeit auf die straße bringen kann wie sie sich nachhaltiger und langfristiger entwickeln kann,
und eine entwicklung dessen ist dass seit schon seit oktober november mehr forciert wird gewerkschaften zu gründen um so ein bisschen nachhaltige strukturen zu bilden auf die man sich verlassen und auf die man im zweifel zurückgreifen kann,
das heißt es wird ganz interessant was jetzt aus denen wird und die zum beispiel wurde anfang februar,
haben sie es geschafft einen relativ also ein streik zu organisieren von angestellten im gesundheitssystem weil sie halt versucht habe zu forcieren dass die grenzen geschlossen werden und das sind tatsächlich dann als k o wird in zu dem zeitpunkt als kurve den hongkong anfing angestellte und trotzdem.
Strecken gegangen.
Das heißt die genau die frage ist dass es inwieweit diese strukturen es schaffen dann eine langfristige basis zu bilden im herbst genau es gibt jetzt auch demnächst wieder war es wird wieder gewählt ich glaube diesmal sind legislative.
Wahlen glaube ich aber jetzt muss ich nochmal genau noch als wird auf jeden fall jetzt wieder gewählt demnächst und leute für andere leute versuchen dann weil im november letztes jahr gab's ja lokal wahlen.
Jetzt wird statt weiter stadtweit gewählt wenn ich das richtig auf dem schirm habe und versuche leute zu forcieren das leute sich dafür registrieren also es wird jetzt wieder auch wenn einfach verschiedene strategien.
Wieder verfolgt bei den leuten klar ist dass es nicht funktioniert hat dass sie nicht so weitermachen können und das mit über nachhaltige arbeiten muss.
Das riecht schon wieder fast noch mal nach einem detaillierteren
update rund um hongkong und die konkrete politische situation bleiben wir vielleicht auch nochmal jetzt hier ganz konkret bei der bekämpfung der ganzen,
corona situation und ich würde es dann ganz gerne nochmal auf,
china und auch nochmal auf diese ursprünge beziehen nämlich diese ganze diskussion die sich jetzt
entfaltet rundum den ursprung und die ursachen dass es denn überhaupt zu diesem zu diesem virus
kommen konnte das ist ja ohnehin eine diskussion die sich enorm verbreitert hier haben wir dann auch im prinzip
die ganze klimawandel diskussion auch nochmal ganz neu auf dem tisch
weil die leute die dieses thema verfolgen natürlich auch sagen
ja das ist halt ein virus der sehr offensichtlich von tieren auf uns übergesprungen ist wie das eigentlich mit fast allen tödlichen viren der letzten jahrzehnte war das spielt natürlich auch mit rein,
dass wir in zunehmenden maße
in umwelt bereiche vor dringend wo tiere leben die so bisher noch kein kontakt hatten und dass dieser kontakt dadurch natürlich immer wahrscheinlicher wird et cetera so,
so die eine achse dann gibt's natürlich die ganze debatte um diesen tiermarkt in wo hahn von dem das ganze jahr nun den
also.
Mein kenntnisstand bisher sozusagen der der der eigentliche grund siro gewesen ist diese ganze situation wenn man sich da halt mal so berichte anschaut wie es da abgeht schon bisschen
anders als so die normale normale wochenmarkt in berlin und natürlich dann damit auch verbunden die ganze esskultur in china,
was hast du da wahrgenommen was inwiefern wird das auch aufgearbeitet oder ist das schon aufgearbeitet was du in den ursprung des virus betrifft.
Also soweit ich weiß man sagt ja jetzt gerade immer was man nicht ist und ich bin keine epidemiologische und keine login von.
Von von daher kann ich da quasi auch nur also soweit ich das gerade verstehe ist man sich relativ sicher dass dieses virus halt von fledermäusen irgendwie gekommen ist wahrscheinlich etwas anderes tier auf den menschen übergesprungen ist wie man das auch schon aussah von saß und mehr kennt,
also was man bei china tatsächlich also es ist tatsächlich so dass der patient über den glaube ich zeichen geschrieben hat,
gar keinen link zu diesem markt hatte und also dieser markt wurde anfang januar geschlossen weil die chinesische oder die vorhanden die regierung in glaube ich ihnen dass das virus damit zusammenhang hängt und das auch definitiv fälle gab die mit dem markt zu tun hatten.
Aber ich weiß nicht ob jetzt wirklich.
Letztendlich und conclusio so dass auf jetzt wirklich wissen dass es dass diese übertragung da irgendwie stattfand ich habe jetzt neulich noch mal gehört dass es zum beispiel auch.
Das es gibt jetzt immer diese vermutung dass es über so ein also ich glaube wie heißen die schuppen sind das schon auf deutsch.
Es ist auf jeden fall so ein relativ exotisches tier das ist das zum beispiel in einer illegalen lieferung von peng.
Schuppen tier ja ja.
Das zum beispiel eine illegale lieferung von schuppen tieren die aus china raus geschmuggelt wurden in virus gefunden wurde das dem aktuellen saskia zwei wo sehr ähnlich ist das heißt ich glaube da ist einfach noch sehr viel unsicherheit und im zweifel sollte man den leuten.
Wieder mehr wissen als ich überlassen ich glaube christian droste hatte gesagt dass er wenn er wenn jemand sehr viel geld geben würde dann würde er
in so exotischen tierzucht orten nach dem in in china nach dem saskia virus suchen weil er vom wohl vermutet dass es über so ein tier auch übersprungen übergesprungen sein könnte auf den menschen,
das heißt.
Also nicht dass es gegessen wurde sondern dass es
einfach leute die in der tierzucht sind die mit diesen seltenen tieren also untypischen haustieren sage ich mal so zu tun haben,
dass die ja sozusagen permanent in kontakt sind dass dass es dort seinen ursprung genommen hat und dann kann es natürlich sein dass jemand der in so einer tierzucht ist auch auf einen tiermarkt
geht ja also in dem moment zeigen den virus schon hatte und es sich dort eben weiter verbreitet hat.
Genau das kann natürlich auch sein dass es über irgendein tier gekommen ist dass auch in der markt verkauft oder so aber also man weiß es es ist halt einfach ja alles noch ist einfach reine spekulation gerade von daher ist es glaube ich etwas wo man mal so ein bisschen vorsichtig sein muss ich glaube eine sache die auch wichtig ist.
In china wird keine fledermaus suppe gegessen das krass dass ich das so sagen muss aber ich,
ging im januar ging ein video ich glaube aus es ging ein video von ich weiß gar nicht von vor was mein video nicht aus china.
Ich glaube es war von einer pazifischen insel wo jemand fledermaus super gegessen hat und das wohl ging dann viral mit dem kommentar ah das ist gegessen wird ich habe in china noch nie davon gehört dass jemand fledermaus suppe ist.
Also ich habe auch verschiedene so so treffen videos von amerikanern die dann auf diesen tier märkten rumgelaufen sind sich mit leuten unterhalten haben die meinten es würde schon alles gegessen werden hier also auch fledermäuse hunde keine ahnung was alles noch rumlag.
Ja ich glaube das ist das was das problem wenn man dann also das ist ich glaube in vielen von dieser aussagen schwingt schenkt viel rassismus mit weil so einzelne.
Einzelfälle und auch wirklich sachen die einfach nicht typisch oder weit verbreitet sind dann als repräsentativ für chinesische esskultur dargestellt werden und die meisten also alle leute die ich in china kenne wenn die sehen was da teils verkauft wird die sagen auch so ach du scheiße was zur hölle.
Die sagen sie finden es auch nicht normal und da muss man auch sagen dass diese tiere märkte wirklich eine absolute verschwinden gierige minderheit darstellen und das ist auch in vielen teilen nicht legal ist.
Also zum beispiel wie auch mit diesen pinken mit diesen schoppenturnieren die da exportiert wurden das ist halt mega geiler tierhandel der dann da stattfindet und ich finde gerade wenn man mit dem also.
Ich finde es immer schwierig videos von irgendwelchen expertin rumlaufen und mit leuten reden so als als evidenz zu benutzen also ich habe ich weiß selber keine daten dazu wie weit diese sachen wirklich weit verbreitet sind dass ich die sagen kann ist das quasi so auf gesellschaftliche ebene das ist nicht das was
also jede es gibt ja zum beispiel irgendwann sieht da gibt's ja dieses dieses hunde festival oder so jedes jahr wenn dieses festival passiert gibt es einen riesigen aufschrei in china
einen sozialen medien sturm gegen dieses festival weil die leute das auch in auch in china ist das nicht akzeptiert irgendwie.
Ich glaube das muss man einfach ganz klar sagen das ist.
Selbst wenn es das gibt also china ist ein land das ist china saarland dass es irgendwie ich glaube flächenmäßig so groß wenn ich größer als europa es gibt provinzen in china die größer sind als,
die provinz von der die meisten leute und europa nie gehört haben ist größer als jedes lied jedes europäische land und das heißt es ist so ein bisschen so.
Als ob man jetzt sagen würde das.
In europa ist es so und so.
Genau also jede merkwürdige sache die vielleicht mit einem kleinen ort irgendwo passiert keine ahnung in irgendwie in bayern gibt es auch wirklich ziemlich merkwürdige bräuche und wenn man dann sagt so ja hier das sind die ganzen europäer oder also.
Ja der weiß russe wundert sich wenn ihm stierköpfe vorgeworfen werden.
Ja genau so ungefähr genau da als wenn man jetzt wenn man es in deutschland in die kämpfe vorwerfen würde.
Von daher ist es ich muss gerade noch so einfach ich glaube muss man sehr vorsichtig sein und ich glaube auch was man bei diesen diskussionen auch immer im hinterkopf behalten muss ist dass einfach sehr sehr viel rassismus einfach mitschwingt also ich kenne das selber und viele leuten,
also auch gerade leute die,
adriatische aussehen als ich und die in deutschland aufgewachsen sind das ist ein ganz weit verbreitetes narrativ dieses rassistischen relativ das in asien essen die leute alles was ich bewegt oder
eine eine schweizer zeitung hat tatsächlich ein etwas abgedruckt wo sie gesagt haben die chinesen essen alles was kreucht und fleucht und das ist halt einfach quatsch,
also das ist es stimmt halt einfach nicht,
und zu sagen und und dann dann sagen leute ja aber sie manche stimmt das ja also es stimmt ja das in südchile teils hunde gegessen werden nicht sehr sympatisch stimmt es auch dass in deutschland kinder missbraucht werden so es gab jetzt gerade diesen riesigen skandal deswegen sagen wir auch nicht das und deutschland kinder missbraucht werden.
Und ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig da dann auch verantwortlich und diesen diskussionen umzugehen und nicht zu pauschalisieren weil letztendlich ist es natürlich wichtig dass man.
Sachlich darüber spricht wo das herkommt und wie du sagst es gibt eben auch diese umwelt diskussion und das ist es gibt ja auch andere viren die zum beispiel bei anderen nutztiere die in europa weit verbreitet sind auf den menschen überspringen können dass man diese diskussion hat sachlich führt aber ich glaube es ist auch sehr wichtig da nicht zu pauschalisieren,
was jetzt in china thermo dein asien gegessen wird weil das letztendlich etwas ist was,
als krasser rassismus dann wieder auf die asiatischen communitys in europa zurückfällt und was dann sich in täglicher diskriminierung.
Wo leute dann vorgeworfen wird sie würden ja irgendwie hund essen oder was man sagt na ja beim asiaten da wird einem ja irgendwie hund oder katze vorgesetzt.
Und wo leute einfach auch täglich angegriffen werden das muss man einfach so das hat einfach wirklich konsequenzen deswegen ist es eine eine eine diskussion die man,
als gesellschaft führen kann aber wo man sich.
Wo man einfach auch klar darüber sprechen muss dass einfach einzelfälle sind und bisher ist es etwas was einfach sehr pauschalisiert wird ich glaube gerade weil es diese idee schon gibt diese diese rassistische idee dass irgendwie in china alles gegessen wird,
muss man sowas auch ansprechen man kann da nicht einfach so sagen ja nee wir haben ja nur über diesen einen markt geredet wir haben ja nie gesagt dass es ganz schöner ist weil die leute dann halt immer sofort daran denken an diese ganzen ideen und dann das muss man einfach wirklich damit muss man super muss man echt verantwortungsvoll umgehen.
Ja ich meine man darf sich dann auch nicht wundern wenn dann die kinder auf rinder wahnsinn ansprechen und kreuz fällt jakob krankheit et cetera nicht,
gut wollte ich jetzt auch gar nicht weiter vertiefen trotzdem hat sich ja im da auch eine entsprechende debatte drum
brand muss man auf jeden fall mal aufgreifen genauso wie diese labor verschwörungstheorie mit diesem genetischen labor in woran was dann auch noch in der nähe dieses markt
das sein soll ja da passt ja wieder alles ganz wunderbar zusammen ich meine bevor wir vielleicht das kurz ansprechen kann man vor allem eins festhalten es ist halt virolent isch klar der
saß auf zwei virus,
kommt von tieren man kann das sehen an den mutationen etcetera hättest du in irgendeiner form eine genetische manipulation gegebenen würde sich das sehr sehr sehr deutlich in so einem virus in dieser arena,
bilden also man kann das klar ausschließen nichtsdestotrotz ist diese diskussion natürlich auch im raum was hat's denn überhaupt auf sich gehabt mit diesem laboren wie hast du das wahrgenommen diese diskussion.
Das ist das schon im januar los das war auch total krass es ist total krass weil ich habe da das gefühl dass ich diese ganzen diskussionen und verschwörungstheorien die ich im januar das erste mal gesehen habe dass sie sich jetzt überall sind das heißt anstatt dass es besser wird wird es schlimmer,
also so,
die diskussion mit dem virus das ging mit dem labor das ging anfangs hieß es dass es eben eine bio waffe sei die aus diesem labor irgendjemand kommen ist und das wurde relativ schnell auch die bank also genau ich habe das auch so wahrgenommen wie du das im endeffekt relativ,
schnell leute die wissen wovon sie reden immer gesagt haben nein man würde das sehen wenn das irgendwie daraus gekommen wäre und.
Das das könnte man die büros auch ansehen es gibt jetzt so eine leichte abwandlung dieser theorie wo leute sagen es ist aus einem labor entkommen.
Diese korona während eben erforscht werden und das ist so ein bisschen so eine nochmal krasse und auch so ein bisschen perfide.
Variation dessen weil im endeffekt also es gibt eine biologin in china sie heißt.
Also die macht im endeffekt so ein bisschen so was ähnliches was auch christian rosten macht also sehr vorstellt korona viren,
sie macht es aber indem sie fledermäuse fängt und versucht diese viren in diesen fledermäusen zu sequenzielle und zu identifizieren
weil halt schon wo seit langem bekannt ist der virus logie das ist halt diese krone wären gibt und auch leute sagen es ist ja wahrscheinlich dass er wieder eine irgendwann auf der menschen um überspringen wird.
Und jetzt wird ihr vorgeworfen dass ein corona virus aus ihrem labor entkommen sei das ist so mit diesen diese neue variationen.
Also die die so ein bisschen was ein virus gibt das corona während erforscht deswegen kommt das dann jetzt daher man muss sagen dass wir wissensstand aktuell ist es gibt keine hinweise darauf,
und auch professor hat in einem interview auch gesagt sobald dieses virus rauskam
ich glaube es war ein interview mit american hat sie sofort diese sequenz des virus mit den sequenzen abgeglichen von den viren die sie in ihrem labor sequenzielle hatten und sie hat sehr erleichtert festgestellt dass es eben nicht ein,
also kein virus war dass sie im labor signalisiert haben.
Und ich höre das jetzt auch immer wieder dass leute sagen die auch mit diesem labor gearbeitet haben das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich dass es es ist nicht so dass da irgendwie es halt ein vernünftiges labor so wo halt entsprechend auch mit den ganzen umgegangen wird.
Natürlich heißt es nicht dass es keine unfälle geben kann und keine versehen geben kann und so aber ich glaube bisher gibt es einfach.
Es ist so.
Es ist einfach unheimlich viel spekulationen und wenn es da wirklich irgendwie vernünftige beweise geben würde dann würde man würden leute die da experte innendrin sind auch.
Darüber sprechen und die gibt es einfach nicht stattdessen sagen die leute die sich mit dem thema auskennen das ist quatsch.
Es ist auch überhaupt nichts neues also ich erinnere mich da sogar noch aus guten alten hiv zeiten in den achtziger jahren ja als das virus aufkam da ging das ratzefatze erschienen dann auch gleich nochmal ein dicker fetter artikel in der,
ja klammer auf ausgezeichneten klammer zu bist du ja dann hier labore und die und so weiter und das
ja alles gestreut worden das volle programm wo dann die tat sich dann auch noch erdreisten hat dann irgendwie so ein tag später so ja zur veröffentlichung dieses
wussten wir schon dass das nicht stimmt aber wir wollten das mal trotzdem so in die debatte reinschmeißen und so ne so würde heute natürlich irgendwie keiner mehr,
so machen aber dieses dieses dieses konzept von ein virus wird von einem labor in die welt gesetzt oder irgendjemand würde auch nur planen sowas in die welt zu setzen ja wo ich mich wirklich nur fragen kann so,
wer bitte soll davon ein.
Also wer sollte überhaupt davon einen vorteil haben können ja dass dass wir sozusagen jetzt also es gibt ja fast niemanden der von dieser situation,
profitiert und nur um irgendwie mehr gesichtsmasken zu verkaufen also ich glaube das ist dann dann doch wirklich sehr weit hergeholt.
Es ist halt schon also es ist wahrscheinlich einfacher zu sagen weil wenn man sagt es kommt aus dem hat man halt jemand auf die man zeigen kann also,
jetzt in china verschwörungstheorien auf die usa zeigen und jetzt in den usa leute oder im besten leute auf china zeigen,
dann einfacher zu sagen dass etwas von anderen menschen kommt dazu sagen es war dann hat man weiß es glaube ich schon so ein gefühl des kontrollverlustes gibt weil das etwas gibt das ist einfach was einfach aus der natur gekommen ist und uns jetzt.
So sehr die gewählt verändert gerade.
Es ist einfach das ding mit der schuld zuweisung man man man ist hilflos und man möchte gerne dass irgendjemand schuld war den man
dann dafür bestrafen kann um sich irgendwie besser zu fühlen das ist schon ein bisschen absurd aber so scheint die welt noch gestrickt zu sein.
Zum abschluss nochmal ein ganz anderes thema was ich hier natürlich auch noch aufdrängt und dass es eben jetzt in der ganzen debatte mit wie gehen wir jetzt mit dieser situation um was müssen wir jetzt eigentlich machen wird natürlich extrem viel über contact
tracing gesprochen und dabei kommt natürlich auch immer wieder das beispiel südkorea aber da auch das andere länder aus wir haben's ja eben in taiwan auch schon mal
angesprochen dass eben jetzt in asien schon sehr viel erfahrung damit besteht und eben teilweise das ganze auch extrem effizient durchgesetzt wird contact tracing
jetzt erstmal als prozess einer gesundheitsbehörde also das nachverfolgen und
bei uns ist glaube ich dieser begriff jetzt überhaupt das erste mal populär geworden in dieser ganzen debatte ob man denn nicht einen weg finden kann das ganze auch digital zu unterstützen dazu kommt dass eben solche länder wie singapur,
wo er sich eben darin auch schon versucht haben uns verschiedene initiativen gibt jetzt weltweit in irgendeiner form mit moderner technik also mit smartphone basiertes technik dem ganzen noch irgendeiner form vorschub zu
leisten was ist denn dein blick auf also was weißt du über den vorgang dieses contact tracing
an sich und wo vielleicht auch europa davon lernen kann.
Also ich glaube es ist eine wichtige sache die man sagen muss.
Wenn man so in china hongkong und timo gibt es kein automatisiertes contact tracing per app punkt.
Es gibt das gibt es einfach nicht es gibt diese idee dass da viel automatisiert gemacht werden gemacht wurde und das einfach viel getrackt wird aber das stimmt einfach nicht also ich habe.
Mit leuten aus taiwan als auch china darüber gesprochen und die hat mir auch gesagt nein es ist wirklich einfach handarbeit also dass wenn jemand positiv bestätigt wird oder in china sogar wenn es nur ein verdachtsfall gibt.
Dann wird halt manuell also damit hat geschaut man redet mit den leuten und man identifiziert.
Enge kontakte und redet mit denen und die werden dann eben zusammenhang mit johan schnell wenn das enge kontakte dann auch in der quarantäne gestellt werden genauso wird es auch in taiwan gemacht das ist wirklich ein.
Enorm also komplett manueller prozess
in taiwan ich hatte auch mit jemandem was ich hatte mit jemandem von der technischen über das thema gesprochen weil halt eben oft im westen dann viel darüber geredet wird dass du mit apps benutzen würde um contact racing zu betreiben und der hat mir dann aber gesagt das ist.
Also das ist quasi quatsch das mit der app zu machen weil zumindest in taiwan alles noch manuell gemacht wird weil sie haben,
das ist auch etwas was du in korea so ein bisschen gemacht wurde soweit ich das weiß es gibt in beiden ländern ein gesetz also ein epidemie bekämpfung gesetz oder so schön ist glaube ich das solchen bekämpfung gesetz.
Und in korea und taiwan ermöglicht dieses gesetzes den gesundheitsbehörden dann leichter auf bestimmte persönliche daten zu zuzugreifen zum beispiel so location history von einem telefon dann habe ich den mal gefragt okay bringt das dann was der,
das ist auch ein arzt der für die.
Solche bekämpfung behörde arbeitet hintermänner sondern das ist quatsch das bringt uns nichts weil die kontakte die relevant sind für saskia zwei sind so eng dass die leute die namen von den leuten kennen also es sind leute mit denen du viel zeit irgendwie zusammen verbracht hast irgendwo drin.
Meistens
kennen sie den namen der leute oder es war vielleicht jemand mit dem ihr zusammen in der vorlesung saß oder so aber dann ist es etwas was in den kalender der leuten steht dann kann man über die uni gehen und herausfinden wer die anderen personen waren in diesem diesem unterricht saßen.
Also das ist so so der blick aus taiwan und in in in china ist das ähnlich also es gibt da auch,
kein interessiertes contact tracing was mir von dem ich weiß wobei man da wieder wichtig ist contact tracing bezeichnet als begriff quasi diesen diesen prozess von es gibt einen positiven fall und wir versuchen jetzt herauszufinden wem diese person kontakte hatte um.
Leute zu finden die sich vielleicht bei der person angesteckt haben könnten und vielleicht auch um herauszufinden wer die person selber angesteckt hat.
Aber das wird dann so viel zusammengeworfen weil eine sache die in taiwan halt tatsächlich passiert und die auch in korea genutzt wird was ich eben schon erwähnt habe dass dieses fancy wo.
Location daten von handys überwacht werden um sicherzustellen dass leute in ihrer quarantäne bleiben aber zum einen ist es keine app,
sondern sachen die es läuft über die telefonnummer und zum anderen ist das etwas was für die quarantäne ist und was mit dem contact tracing selber nichts zu tun hat,
und also taiwan entwickelt jetzt tatsächlich gerade eine app die so ähnliches wie das über das wir gerade in deutschland reden.
Sie meinen auch dieser compliance also das würde mich interessieren ob das wirklich der fall sein wird dann aber also auch diese diese ganzen prozesse seit manuell.
Dass man dazu aber auch im hinterkopf behalten muss ist dass taiwan also der der vertreter der technischen behörde hat dann auch gesagt sie haben auch.
Für eine weile versucht leute zu contact tracer die nur ein verdacht auf kobe neunzehn haben und es konnten sie aber nicht weil ihnen einfach die kapazitäten fehlten.
Das ist einfach der punkt wo er halt halt dann auch sagte dass dieses content-marketing ist ein skill,
man braucht relevantes wissen man braucht die skills man muss leute dazu bringen einem zu vertrauen und muss vernünftig eine konversation mit leuten haben und da muss man auch einschätzen können aus sicht welche kontakte jetzt irgendwie relevant sind das heißt es ist nicht so dass man einfach
sich irgendwelche studis anstecken und sagt die machen das jetzt sondern es ist halt schon etwas wo man leute ausbilden muss und es kapazitäten immer über lange zeit braucht
bauen muss und die man nicht kurzfristig einfach hoch fahren kann.
Und taiwan war einfach nie an einem punkt wo es neue fälle nicht manuell kontaktraten konnte also die es gab tabak hatte ich glaube der der peak von neuen fällen pro tag war irgendwie.
Oder so also wirklich ein terror nie mehr als siebenundzwanzig neue fälle pro tag und das heißt es befindet sich auf einem ganz anderen einen ganz anderen punkt.
Der das ausbruchs ich glaube eine sache die man vielleicht.
Daraus lernen kann einerseits also ich glaube es gab jetzt in deutschland auch diese unterhaltung so ein bisschen das wenn man es schaffen würde die fälle runterzukriegen auf irgendwie ich glaube zwei oder dreihundert pro tag ist der wert der nichts mehr gehört habe dann könnte man auch in deutschland.
Je nachdem bis tausend genau.
Genau dann könnte man auch in deutschland manuell contact tresor.
Und also das ist im endeffekt was das tabak angeschafft hat aber der unterschied ist natürlich dass in taiwan die meisten fälle immer noch von außerhalb gekommen ist und jetzt von deutschland in deutschland die meisten fälle von innerhalb kommen,
ich glaube eine sache die ich mich so ein bisschen frage wenn diese lektion aus taiwan sich auch in deutschland repliziert also diese.
Diese aussage dass zum beispiel so generelle location daten nicht hilfreich sind.
Dann frage ich mich halt schon ob wir dann vielleicht in keine ahnung zwei drei monaten an einem punkt sind wo man das mal fragt und sagt okay benutze diese daten eigentlich und wurde die content creator sagen nö die daten benutzen wir nicht von den apps weil das ist sowieso nutzlos weil das sind alles kontakte die nicht eng genug sind.
Also es ist halt keine spekulation.
Natürlich ist es alles spekulation weil natürlich diese systeme jetzt überhaupt erstmal entstehen ich selber bin ja ja nicht ganz so
pessimistisch vielleicht nochmal ein paar anmerkungen zu dem was du gesagt hast also zunächst einmal muss man natürlich sagen taiwan hat natürlich ein extrem vorteil
in anführungsstrichen dadurch dass sie eine insel sind das heißt in dem moment wo sie etwas in
im land unter kontrolle haben ist relativ klar von wo es kommen kann da ist natürlich jetzt so die situation in deutschland mit tausenden von grenzübergängen offenen grenzen etcetera also das ist einfach
gerade europa das ist so eine gemengelage pendler veranstaltungen tun ja dann noch so ihr ihr nächstes und in der situation wo auch großveranstaltung abgesagt sind.
Ja da ist es dann vielleicht eben auch noch händelbar und einfacher nur kann es eben sehr schnell gehen in südkorea das ja auch angesprochen hat ist haben sie ja dann auch entsprechende
krasse maßnahmen das heißt in dem moment wo dann in dieser religiösen gemeinschaft da gab's so eine sekte keine ahnung was das ganz genau war wo es halt vermehrte fälle gab da haben sie auch einfach diese komplette gemeinschaft dann auch mal unter quarantäne gestellt
das muss ich dann eben auch noch zeigen wie solche maßnahmen dann eben auch hier mit unserem freiheitlich individualistischen ansatz dann,
verknüpfen lassen wird und natürlich wollen natürlich langfristig auch großveranstaltungen wieder haben also wir wollen bars klubs
partys festivals messen konferenzen et cetera haben und dann kann.
Kann es natürlich sehr schnell passieren dass außer kontrolle gerät weil es war ja auch in deutschland unter kontrolle also die fälle in münchen und am fast ganz genau gab's noch einen zweiten vorfall kannst jetzt gerade nicht zuordnen aber es gab vor allem dieses eintragen in münchen das,
konnte noch sehr schnell nachvollzogen werden mit den kapazitäten und methoden die die gesundheitsämtern hier haben derzeit oder zum
dem zeitpunkt zumindest hatten aber dann kam halt der karneval und dann kam halt fußballveranstaltungen vielleicht auch noch mit
rein das war in italien dann auch vor allem so ein super spray event offensichtlich wo es dann eben schnell außer kontrolle geraten kann dann diese verbreitung mit
dem engen kontakt auch da gibt es in letzter zeit ein paar interessante studie hat jetzt zum beispiel gerade was gesehen auch eine studie aus china wo halt so eine.
Übertragung aus einem restaurant studiert wurde wo offensichtlich eine klimaanlage nicht ganz erheblich
dazu beigetragen hat dass da so eine größere gruppe die um eine andere gruppe herum saß sich auch noch den virus eingefangen hat also was ich damit sagen will
es gibt einfach verschiedene situationen die umso mehr wir einer in anführungsstrichen normalität hinzu kommen,
unkontrollierbare sind wo sich dann eben die frage stellt haben wir eine chance dass
manuelle normale contact tracing zu unterstützen.
Das,
das ist glaube ich auch einfach dass wir das muss man auch einfach dass es auch einfach dieses wichtige kariert beim fall von taiwan insgesamt mittlerweile nur knapp ich glaube vierhundertvierzig fälle sind es vielleicht mittlerweile das heißt das ist unheimlich klein,
das heißt statistisch wenn wir sagen dass irgendwie keine ahnung vielleicht zehn prozent aller fälle in so situationen übertragen zum beispiel in china gab's auch einen fall wo jemand in einem bus angesteckt wurde,
wir sagen jetzt vielleicht zehn prozent dieser fälle in so solchen situationen stattfinden und bei taiwan der großteil der fälle nicht nicht innerhalb des landes übertragen wurde da kann es auch total gut sein dass sie einfach noch keine fälle von solchen übertragungen hatten weil's einfach so wenig fälle in taiwan gibt.
Und das ist einfach auch diese dieses riesige wert dass wir irgendwann einfach sehr sehr vorsichtig damit mit sein muss inwieweit man sagt etwas was in taiwan funktioniert dann wird hier funktionieren.
Ist ja auch in in europa ein ding es kommt zum beispiel auch in in in polen zum einsatz aber da eben nicht über das mobilfunknetz an eben tatsächlich über solche apps.
Ich glaube eines also zwei sachen die ich tatsächlich glaube die man in die die man,
lernen kann vielleicht ist also ich glaube eine sache ist zum beispiel dass die öffentliche kommunikation in taiwan also sowohl der mensch von der taiwanesischen cds als auch die diese chinesische bio statistikerin mit der ich gesprochen habe die haben beide gesagt das wichtigste ist dass man die öffentlichkeit,
public also dass man gutes messaging hat und dass die leute wissen was los ist dass die maßnahmen für sinnvoll erachtet werden dass die leute wissen wie sie damit umgehen also das ist selber die tools haben selber gute entscheidungen zu fällen das ist einfach ganz wichtiger teil.
Ich glaube der andere sache da bin ich gespannt ob darüber.
Darüber absehbarer zeit mal eine diskussion haben wenn es eben diese quarantäne und isolation von den leuten die dann als enge kontakte identifiziert werden weil.
Was professor linn eben gesagt hat also sie hat es sehr betont dass in johan eben die lehre war dass man.
Wenn man den leuten nur sagt sie muss quarantäne machen dass sich die im zweifel nicht dran halten,
dass dann das virus sich weiter verbreitet das heißt es reicht ja nicht nur zur contact tracer und die leute zu ihren defiziten die enger kontakte sind das ist ja so ein bisschen gerade der punkt an dem sich die debatte in deutschland befindet sondern dass man die engen kontakt dann.
Überwachen muss für zwei wochen um sicher zu gehen dass sie das virus nicht haben.
Und in diesen zwei wochen möchte man die die idee ist halt die leute denn diesen zwei wochen zu unter quarantäne zu stellen damit sie es wenn also im idealfall erwischt man sie bevor sie selber infektiös sind stellt sich unter quarantäne,
und dann lässt man die nach zwei wochen wieder raus und dieses ding wird ihr benutzt um in diesem schritt.
Diese quarantäne zu entschlossen in in taiwan und in china wurde das gemacht indem man leute halt in hotels steckt die halt von der regierung dann operiert werden und ich glaube das ist so der nächste schritt wo es wo ich mir vorstellen könnte dass man da vielleicht mal eine gesellschaftliche debatte darüber braucht weil,
genau ich würde auch sagen was auch in was auch in taiwan und was auch die leute in singapur und den korea alle sagen ist diese daten die ganzen daten die man sammelt die können das manuelle contact tracing unterstützt und vielleicht so ein bisschen schärfen.
Mit dem man dazu den zusätzliche informationen gibt und der nächste schritt ist dann die frage was macht man denn dann wenn man diese engen kontakt hat und ich da bin ich tatsächlich gespannt wie die debatte dann in deutschland läuft,
dann ist es natürlich schon eine frage und ich weiß auch nicht wie der deutschland die rechtliche lage ist ob man sagen kann dass man dann bei leuten zwei wochen lang wirklich zwanghaft die bewegungsfreiheit einschränken kann weil man sagt zu kriegen wie unter kontrolle,
und das ist also eigentlich eine ganz große halt auch wieder sehr grundsätzliche so rechts und freiheitsfreund und das ist auch ein tabak nicht unumstritten.
Ja also ich meine das ganze hängt natürlich dann auch mit der frage der verfügbarkeit und geschwindigkeit von tests ab
nicht wahr aber ist ja ist ja nun mal so wenn ich jetzt eine in berlin eine halbe stunde in der s-bahn stehe um ins andere ende der stadt zu fahren und stehe halt die ganze zeit oder irgendein nehmen jemand der
der halt infektiös ist und beide hätten,
also nicht unbedingt wissen ja sondern eben unwissend weil von woanders reingeholt dann.
Kann halt hier über die apps tatsächlich diese nähe festgestellt werden und man hat eben ein werkzeug über das man dann eben eine warnung aussprechen kann um leute die einfach vollkommen
ohne vermutungen sind dass sie sich in gefahr gebracht haben in dem moment dort zu sagen so hier,
bei dir könnte hol dir mal einen test so dann,
musst du auch nicht vierzehn tage zuhause sitzen so und besser ist das für dich und und und und deine familie ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass das dass das greifen kann aber das werden wir halt sehen festzuhalten bleibt.
Auch in asiatischen ländern ist das noch nicht dieses ganze phänomen von ich sag mal
app unterstützen contact tracing ist und wir werden schauen ob das in irgendeiner form am ende einen unterschied macht oder nicht.
Katharina vielen vielen dank für deine ausführungen hier zu all diesen schwierigen fragen.
Danke dir.
Und wer lust hat noch tiefer ins asiatische geschehen einzusteigen fernost werts podcast cover weiß ich wie oft macht ihr sendungen derzeit so.
Wir veröffentlichen einmal pro monat also immer am ersten mittwoch des monats und wenn es sich hier gibt gibt es sondersendungen zwischendurch.
Okay.
Und genau dann halt auch den newsletter alle zwei wochen oder gerade weil ich gerade viel zu tun aber in der uni einmal pro monat aber.
Der dann per e-mail kommt ok super ja danke nochmal.
Und vielen dank fürs zuhören bei u k w hier geht's natürlich auch wieder weiter mit corona nächste folge dann voraussichtlich mit pavel.
In unserem corona wo wir die ganze spannende entwicklung um die apps und natürlich auch die sonstigen zahlen wieder.
In angriff nehmen werden bis dahin sage ich jetzt erstmal.